[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yes sir
top of the morning top of the morning
going on realm how are we doing out here
sunday service
y'all know what it is lloyd metroid i
see you gerald mack in the building
making sure everybody's respectful
salute to you brother i always see you
pop knock i want to say pop drop and
drop but it's popped out too pop not too
soon to be the lord's time you know what
i'm saying how's that motivated what's
going on brother on my level
i think i might find a good setting
right now that i like
bunty wagon
bang bang heated heavy gang early nine
is gang early you know what it is
yeah
yeah best possible scenario i think for
the nfc championship game but that's
just me back from dead my destiny
bredrin good to play some games with you
earlier this week death mobile what's up
lydian master what's going on game
plateau asante my god yo ksrt my vr
brother
zenith we gotta talk about it i'm gonna
have some things to say pick that up and
it's on a quest thank you hustle i
appreciate it it's our quest um
it's on psvr it's on steam vr
brah it's something man getting fired
what's going on alex psx is going on you
know what i mean oh yeah we gonna rock
it the cog is here you already know but
yeah we got a fun show lined up the
boxing burger long overdue uh thank you
commander adamus yeah i'm i'm on the
edge of my seat man we got a chance to
do something special we'll see i didn't
predict this i'm not gonna say i did
with my niners but hey we're in position
let's see what happened alan victor
what's going on
yeah check that out k x coin what's
going on little man oh you got the
little man for walmart yeah yeah yeah
it's a beast you know what i'm saying
gabriel fires okay you're getting that
vr that's what's up but yeah it's gonna
be a good show we got boxing burger
pulling up
king pulling up attic i guess he's going
at it going to make sure i talk to
[Music]
will definitely be coming in hot so
we'll start the show most likely without
him but we're gonna have some fun jay
vargas was going oh bx stand up oh
that's a that's a boogie down
representative in the higher law chat
you know i gotta show extra favoritism
what's going on jay barley where you
from what was that south south bx north
be excellent part of the x man
[Music]
so look we're gonna get this thing going
fun
show definitely ain't gonna be six hours
so if you would try to do that thing
again i'll be like yeah thank you cog
for my whole shift last week no
that's probably like a once in a
generational type situation but salute
to everybody that came out that was a
lot of fun but i will catch y'all in a
minute we gotta get my man's boxing
burger in here you know king about to
come in here with the music stitch
switch coming out i see them switch
emojis [ __ ] i see you you know saying
oh kingsbridge okay king's bridge yeah
yeah yeah i see you jay vargas yeah yeah
i got people over there shopping over
there that
summer boulevard fordham road all that
you know
but anyway yeah decado no six hour for
you no
[Music]
all right i'm gonna tell y'all
shout out to park chester i see you
terminal reality that's a bx i i got a
rapper i had to break protocol i see you
about brock's representatives oh
brownsville mop bash out posse let's go
we'll go okay we got a lot of new york
is up in here today i like that i'm
biased
i gotta go
[Music]
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is
up in the apartment they call the
department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals follow on twitter
[Music]
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all haven't messed up and turned
me to an animal and haters be swearing
they real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable this
is that
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until the time to get this
show started so um
look y'all missed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is that yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we were messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell an uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
[Music]
and turn me to an animal and headless be
swearing they real but come to find out
that they really mechanical and yeah
i'll be eating these rappers but that's
all a part of me being accountable and
they say i'm better than money because
you can bank on me being accountable i
know a million rappers that don't want
to be on a song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i'm addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable this is that
this
love my city but i'm still by coastal i
got it
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
hear you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and headless be swearing they
real but coming to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on the song with me that's
understandable i kill a beat and they
want to compare me to freddie and jason
i'd rather be hannibal they'd be like
why use a video game just be original
y'all so dramatical i know it's random
but i am addicted to flipping the sample
and making it flammable
this is the yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back with messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh
i guess i'm here to keep you entertained
until it's time to get this show started
so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i'll be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we
[Music]
look i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled to be your dog thing very loyal
but i ain't gonna hold you i ain't here
to boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you i always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger that's
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so
um look y'all messed up and turned me to
an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they're
really mechanical and yeah i'll be
eating these rappers but that's all a
part of me being accountable and they
say i'm better than money because you
can bank on me being accountable i know
a million rappers that don't want to be
on a song with me that's understandable
i kill a beat and they want to compare
me to freddie and jason i'd rather be
hannibal they'd be like why use a video
game just be original y'all so
dramatical i know it's random but i'm
addicted to flipping the sample and
making it flammable this is that
fire this is their yoga fire flame they
think it's arson up in the apartment
they call the department and i get the
blame still i'll be running collecting
them rings you just a target when i'm in
the range i was the hardest to start
regardless back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my
[Music]
boy you you ain't gotta say it i'm
embarrassed for you always been a nerd
never been a loser making voltron with a
gang of cougars and i'm going places
better tell her uber cause it's pretty
hard to sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they're really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the snapple and making it
flammable this is that
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boy you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i always
been a nerd never been a loser making
voltron with a gang of cougars and i'm
going places better tell her uber cause
it's pretty hard to sleep on freddy
krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being a cannibal and they say i'm better
than money because you can bank on me
being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i'm addicted to flipping
the sample and making it flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them rings
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging
[Music]
guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you outta messed up and turned me
to an animal and haters be swearing they
real but come to find out that they
really mechanical and yeah i be eating
these rappers but that's all a part of
me being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm
[Music]
gotta say it i'm embarrassed for you
i've always been a nerd never been a
loser making voltron with a gang of
cougars and i'm going places better tell
her uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep
on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lord's podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be keeping these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back when you was messaging people on
aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal i got it
[Music]
you ain't got to say it i'm embarrassed
for you i've always been a nerd never
been a loser making voltron with a gang
of cougars and i'm going places better
tell her uber cause it's pretty hard to
sleep on freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look y'all messed up and turned me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but coming to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't want to be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they want to compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping
when i'm in the range i was the hardest
to start regardless back we was
messaging people on aim check my vocals
all on twitter but i'm anti-social love
my city but i'm still by coastal
um
[Music]
i guess you could say that i'm very
spoiled for them to be your dog thing
very loyal but i ain't gonna hold you i
ain't here to boil you you ain't gotta
say it i'm embarrassed for you i've
always been a nerd never been a loser
making voltron with a gang of cougars
and i'm going places better tell her
uber cause it's pretty hard to sleep on
freddy krueger
let's do that again
here you hear you man welcome to the
show if you would not mind go ahead and
uh find yourself a spot get comfortable
grab a snack do all that good stuff that
we need to do and um you know we're
about to get started i am well it's not
important who i am uh what's important
is that you are pulling up to the iron
lords podcast right now as we speak and
uh i guess i'm here to keep you
entertained until it's time to get this
show started so um
look you gotta mess up and turn me to an
animal and haters be swearing they real
but come to find out that they really
mechanical and yeah i be eating these
rappers but that's all a part of me
being accountable and they say i'm
better than money because you can bank
on me being accountable i know a million
rappers that don't wanna be on a song
with me that's understandable i kill a
beat and they wanna compare me to
freddie and jason i'd rather be hannibal
they'd be like why use a video game just
be original y'all so dramatical i know
it's random but i am addicted to
flipping the sample and making it
flammable
this is their yoga fire flame they think
it's arson up in the apartment they call
the department and i get the blame still
i'll be running collecting them reigns
you just a target when i'm in the range
i was the hardest to start regardless
back we was messaging people on aim
check my vocals all on twitter but i'm
anti-social love my city but i'm still
by coastal
[Music]
embarrassed for you i've always been a
nerd never been a loser making voltron
with a gang of cougars and i'm going
places better tell her uber cause it's
pretty hard to sleep on freddy krueger
[Music]
is
[Music]
in the attic i wanted to chill with the
pack and be like a young wolf but then
they would mistake me for attic if i can
imagine it's cool to give you some
advice then invite your girl to your
squadron cause if you don't give her
that option you're gonna be single
player like siren you're gonna get
tossed in the bushes by king david
royalty not a pretender detrimental to
an elemental what's the avatar to a knee
bender i gotta be me though i know it's
my destiny worked a cognito who cares if
you fly if you steal a mosquito you
swear you ain't something but really
you like to collect stuff and that's
cool but i got bad news even if you
really was that joke king david still be
the king of the statues since the
juvenile i've been cursed with a curse
to be musical and if you hate it we'll
meet in the crucible was it in nothing
it's cool and it's beautiful we let you
know that your dreams are pursuable
whatever you want to do then is doable
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on the lord's day
if you got work on a sunday it's
suitable cause you can listen to this in
your cubicle on a lord's day
[Music]
and the bike is hot
and we are live hear ye hear ye and
welcome to the iron lords podcast llc
and also live on lords of gaming.net
episode number 242. it's another
glorious sunday we're back at the round
table on the lord's date i'm extremely
excited about our special guest and
we've got xbox's strong q2 performance
respawn star wars games
gears collection rumors and certain
affinity leaks to discuss so we gonna
get right into it i want to introduce a
lord whose steady rise and evolution as
a content creator has truly been
enjoyable to watch
whether it be his fantastic tech
analysis or outstanding video production
all done with a pure passion for the
games industry
introducing the creator of the boxing
burger youtube channel host of the world
of gaming podcasts and a panelist of the
xbox factor and midweek mix up podcasts
the lord of gaming enthusiasm
artists formerly known as archimedes
who always reminds everyone to game on
live from germany and finally making his
debut into the realm of the lords
my man lord boxing burger how we doing
sir
uh how can i do bad after such an epic
intro
thank you so much i'm super excited to
be here kind of feels like i made it to
the champions league i'm i'm really
looking forward to hang with you guys
thanks so much for the invite absolutely
man you are a lord in your realm at what
you do man what you been playing what's
been going on with you man
yeah
i've been jumping in between a lot of
games lately um my go-to game is
actually age of empires 4 right now i
play that almost every day um just love
it nice so so good i don't know whether
any of you have played it um but yeah
it's it's amazing rts action what else
you would play
yeah i
with all the activision talk i went back
to a couple of activision games i played
a little bit diablo 2 the remaster from
last year and i went back to tony hawk
a lot of fun
god bless tony hawk
diablo
i would have had that activision of
fever as well i was just waiting for
that eventual
game pass
i think that's coming soon activision's
games never really hit like that for me
so i feel like i just like when they're
owned
and it's a service that i prefer
just say it just say yeah it does that
okay
yes i i'm officially i'm officially
black and white so i have a green fraud
alert oh my god
yo i'm done i'm done
so that's been pretty much it yeah no i
and i started the other day uh scarlet
nexus actually i saw that
yesterday i'm really enjoying the
gameplay and i'm enjoying the graphics
and everything but these there are these
dialogues in between the gameplay
elements are too long for me i don't
know i'm skipping them right now yeah
it's like
you need to listen to 10 minutes of
dialogue to get to play five minute of
an actual level and then you have to
listen again to 10 minutes of time
are you implying you're not a fan of
that uh
anime slash jrpg exposition
oh on the contrary actually i i enjoy a
lot of uh pictures just i don't know the
way how this is presented at the
dialogues um it's just it's not a cut
scene per se it's it's just i don't know
whether anyone played it but definitely
not just characters and slide them out
in the side and it's like a dialogue
between two people right after that just
happened and it's really something
mundane like oh i see you checking out
that girl
random and i come on i want to kill
those monsters
let's go fight and he's worrying about a
date and i'm just like i really don't
like this part right here so
same thing with you i i skipped those
two
it's really not a no nothing against
chair but i love them man one of my most
actually my second most played game of
last year was uh octopath traveller yeah
like 85 hours into that last year so uh
definitely not against that um it's just
with with uh scarlett i'm i'm torn and
probably it's because of the combat
itself is so much fun yeah they are
lovely yeah we'll get into it they will
definitely get it no doubt good to have
you here and you know we got the four
horsemen of gaming those original lords
of the round table
pulling up extra hot right now i can't
even come in with my music
coming in extra hot right now but it's
starting with my with the co-host my
brother from another mother the
difficult game conqueror lord of his own
world and the how of the young wolf my
man in a different time zone
multiverse
lord addict how are we doing sir
so uh as you guys could see i'm talking
from the 80s
uh you know it's it's 100 sir
1800s i didn't know black tvs existed in
the 1800s
what's going on crazy
they're doing pretty good man i've been
playing them games man playing the games
they've been playing really nice
i don't know if i'm like technically i
see people tweeting yeah i see people
tweeting about i'm playing dying light
too i mean i see people tweeting all the
time they're playing dying late too
so you know definitely next week
come in uh i i'll give my
my examples of uh dying light too we'll
have a review up on the channel probably
wednesday or tuesday or whatever that
embargo lifts mm-hmm i'll have to look
into that yeah i think it's i see look
huh i muted no you're good no no you're
good oh no it's someone keeps saying the
60s listen
people
i say what time frame i want this to be
you don't dictate that if i want it to
be the 50s it'll be the damn 15.
look like he's recording an al qaeda
video
yo like somebody's hostage and there's a
there's a demand there's a ransom and if
you don't
this is the ransom video
oh he's got the scully just going let's
go at it
[Music]
is i get my green
roller my green at fraud alert i get a
snack bar in the upstairs basement oh my
god it's in the upstairs basement whoa
how fire are you living this guy right
here man he's unreal
it's crazy if you look at it when i'm
talking in the black what since my
filter is black and white and you put
that fraud alert on the front alerts the
only thing color right
salute
until i get my green fraud alert i'm
gonna be in the 80s
listen that you got to take that up with
the iron bank that's usoff i'm out of
this i'm neutral oh if you can find me a
fraud alert siren or whatever the hell
you call it that i told him
i told him where to go get it he can
look up anything on the web and he
decides not to anyway and uh
exactly what is the upstairs basement
and of course we have our most technical
gaming lord the solo gaming list for the
single player selfish experience and
also the sastradamus the lord of clarity
and lord patriot of the green fraud
alert iron bait
my man coming in hot lord sovereign how
we doing sir ah super high i'm a hot
mess today
damn the snow oh
bro shoveling yesterday shoveling today
yeah yeah yeah you know i'm looking very
rotten
but it's the only one
almost a foot of snow but continue sir
yeah yeah so i'm good though i actually
did get the game a little bit um not
exactly what i was expecting to i still
haven't finished halo infinite maybe
i'll get to do that this week
um so yesterday two things so yesterday
i tried to i was trying to download the
uh the upgraded uncharted collection on
the ps5 um
this is a funny thing because it's not
throwing shade at anything uh-oh but the
amount of dust that was on that machine
no
i'm not even trying to i'm not trying to
i'm not trying to start anything so this
is how we get labeled in with king
as someone as someone who uses their
playstation for exclusives
it's a little bit dry lately you know
what i mean so february is lit okay
i'm excited did it look at you and say
thank you
[Laughter]
so i was trying to download that and the
thing is that the the uncharted games
that that
game share with kaibatsu so
they were on his account so i couldn't
get the 10 upgrades i was waiting for
him to do all that so i could download
the legacy collection for the 10 it's
not the 50 dollars
anyway
yes it worked it worked okay because i
tried it i wasn't able to upgrade
what i did
so if you if you get if you've got
uncharted 4
um through the uh whatever collection
the uh whatever yeah the ps plus
collection that doesn't count it doesn't
count no no um i
no i have it i also bought the the dlc
the what's it called um legacy lost
legacy
you had that and nothing i have that uh
wow no no whenever i go to the store it
says 50 and not 10 so that's right
that's not supposed to happen
i told you swipe
card sorry about that
i apologize for adding to this
why are you apologizing for something i
told you what was gonna happen
just get the checkbook ready so anyway i
i didn't get a chance to play that so
you know what shame on me something that
i haven't played yet what's up and i've
started like a million times
i never finished
uh the last of us left behind
i never finished it i started a million
times i finally sat down while i waited
for that
and and i played it wow man
druckmann is fairly
i can't wait until he comes over to xbox
like everybody
now another the other thing that i
played was on the switch but it's also
on game pass but i have time to play on
game pass it's a game called record of
lotus war right and it's the the
subtitles like detail it something
labyrinth something
it's a metroidvania king are you talking
about the one you talk about the one
with the elf
yeah
yo it looks crazy
yo it is so beautiful looking
and the animations are fantastic it's a
metroidvania
king i don't know if you remember
dreamcast record of lotus war yes it was
like a diablo like right it was cool it
was a cool but it was in the same
universe this is something totally
different it's a side call of mine but
you know this is taken from that yes oh
so it's like a wreck uh right after okay
okay so after you finish that one in the
dreamcast right um
it's it's the ending of the war that's
why she doesn't remember things in the
beginning yes and she's like i know you
what i know about what are you talking
about exactly right
it's hot it is so hot i i'm i'm up to
the last boss the last boss is so janky
um
it's going to make you just put it down
for a little bit to come back together
let's go but it is a beautiful game uh
wow i was i was amazingly impressed
animations and bonkers yeah so i played
it on switch because i don't have time
to sit down and play it on on games
though
but man yeah
but i gotta say though when things get
things get hot and heavy in that game
yeah yeah the frame on the frame right
right
okay
shout out to the switch it wasn't it
wasn't an all-natural situation
it was not it was not all night
[Laughter]
of course we have the incredible hunk of
this aka the access gamer ooh
the prophet of xbox swami king of the
statues who defends nothing less than
that premium experience it is the leader
of the fraud alert movement
b love it lord king how we doing sir
oh so where what is this three weeks
into uh 30 30 days of uh king jackets
i was trying to figure out which one i'm
gonna take a picture of the back of this
jacket because this is the reason why i
got it it's a wolf and i'm like oh man
we was on this path for a minute
it's so crispy um that you can hear the
leather still trying to get acclimated
that's what it's gonna do with this
chris
yeah you know you know i was just buying
and just putting them up and just you
know go in the store and be like yo let
me get five of those you know
let's get it
make spaces about that
what you've been up to sir
fortnight and fortnite only
nice
yo i i've come to conclusion
right now that i think that they put
subliminals in this game
it's crack if that's what it is it's
crackers it has to be because on god in
them i can be sleep and this is a
gumball song right because i got to this
gumball dude right and i got the gumball
guy out and um
he's so dope because he's a gumball
machine and he eats gumballs
so you know his the cute animation of
him looks very nice
but when you see the artwork of the dude
he's a savage he has teeth and he kills
gum gumballs like
so
it's it's so dope but there's a song
that goes with it right because each
page in a season pass is like a theme
yeah and you have to get out that whole
thing to get to the next uh page
it's a gumball song wow and it's so
catchy and it's so lit that i'm dreaming
in my sleep
so that's when you know the game got you
when you think about the music in it
yeah it's a sublim they got something
going on in there that that makes me
forgo all the stuff that i'm playing
something's up there and i really want
to get to the bottom of it so if
anybody's a private investigator please
hit me up so we're going to go and you
know scout out what epic is going but
other than that i've been playing little
stuff here and there but um i got to get
on my oculus i saw you put 7 p.m
tonight uh
i might have to slide up through here
bro slide through it then we got to talk
there's some stuff on it when it's what
it's up to me i'm going to tell you
what's going on right now it's some
stuff to play some stuff to play for
sure
no doubt but um yeah if that's it for
you king i will jump in oh yeah and um i
do apologize for all the people out
there trying to figure out what happened
with my [ __ ]
i was in the shower right and i said
i grabbed the die and i said if i do
this i'm going to be later than i am
[Laughter]
listen so so i i have to look i have to
look a big sub paul
he just said he just said he picked up
the die i think that's the guy he just
said he picked up to die i think that
that means it's not all natural no no no
no i never said [ __ ]
next year god bless you let's keep it
let's go come on let's get moving anyway
and of course we have the gaming ninja
himself the shinobi cognito spread that
realism around the iop not telling you
what you want to hear what you need to
hear shout out to my mains mr maddie
plays shout out to defining duke shout
out to randolph shout out to chess
quarter we did the little collaboration
episode you know saying little avengers
joint it was really good it's up right
now free on youtube if you didn't catch
it earlier the week so check that out we
also had um crossover episode crazy if
you all want to support the patreon with
um sacred symbols
and defining duke so all avengers you
know he was on both sides of that
argument but it was good we came
together got some commonality there that
was that shout out to our last word my
boy ibontes thai guy travis hilarious
episode just talk about what's going on
and then pr talk about obviously which
korean prep and bungie's new ip we're
getting some little little more inklings
on that so check that out for that um as
far as gaming for me um a little bit of
destiny i was like just doing my little
homework you know my ritual stuff just
to get back let me do my strikes let me
do it just get my materials and all that
stuff up i actually tried the gunk for
the first time i put that to the side
here's my thing about it think about it
i like it the problem i have is i just
wish one they had like a bigger budget
to make it like if this game was a
beautiful really pristine looking game
it'll be crazy it's just like you could
feel a little bit of the double a in the
equality on the graphical presentation
of it but it was a small group right i
know i know like i'm in my mind i'm like
this could be a like this is one of
those ones i want them to stick with
that's basically what i'm doing
this could be a banger if
a little bit more attention to graphic
like it looked like a jacket dexter what
i'm saying that that type of fidelity
with what they're doing with the gunk
and the thing in the beautiful world how
far did you make it into like chapter
three you know what i'm saying okay so
when you get a little bit further you're
gonna see the budget start to expand
okay okay um and it's it's a lot of
things that a little subtle things what
i thought it was it felt very
nintendo-esque yes yes um early 64. yeah
type of stuff yes um i was i loved the
platforming of it i loved the thought
from this uh with the puzzles
um
it was a throwback it's a throwback yeah
and i will say i like the voice dialogue
with the second character who's with you
telling you why you're going on what's
going on are y'all having this nice
banter it was a nice feel i would just
say a little bit more action elements
but again i haven't played long enough
baby
maybe it heats up yeah and then after
that but i think they should stick with
it i think there is potential here well
it is when you get to the end of the
store because i finished it so when you
get to the store end of the story there
is a pathway to other things okay um one
thing i i didn't like about it and and i
and i hope they expand on it when they
first saw the trailer of it yeah it
seemed to me
more action-packed yes i didn't think i
thought it was going to be more
action-packed it really it wasn't
exploratory it's more expensive it's a
real chill game yes but see the boxing
burger i i like that i needed that right
now like right now i didn't need all
this crazy and i like the little upgrade
pack
it's just the right enough game for me
right now so i was it was a good space
but i could understand people wanting
more quick resume helps those
exploratory games so much because like
when you got to go and you turn your
stuff off you come back and you're right
back where you were at and these
exploratory games that you don't have to
find a safe space and stuff
i think that really helps the the
working uh individual you know people
that have a lot of stuff going on
and that game really helped me with that
yeah so the other dre and the legend i
gotta plug it you know shout out to
kaibabs we shot the volakas shout out to
sinister we're supposed to just play
after the fall which is um oculus um
kind of like a four player
um
left 4 dead con and joint right
cool i like it the only thing is they
lost me on one part when it's like we
already friends in the damn um ui but
then when you're getting the game all
right give me your switch nintendo
social security card number so we can
join up in the lobby and then now once
you do it one time you're good but i'm
like why i got to do this so that kind
of messed me up and then sinister got
bumped and then he couldn't do a
rejoining progress so he was like
it's still good it's it's a great game
but they got to work that friends up the
game i gotta get here and talk about
right now is zenith the last city yeah
that's all you talking about bro all
right so i threw that on
and i'm like we're gonna play this for
like 15 to 20 minutes to see what it is
see what's going on you know whatever
whatever
all right let me get the bad out the way
first let's get a bad offer all right
first y'all got the worst custom chris
shout out to mama michael who we had but
when we had mama michael yeah louise
talk about custom creatives it
represents
representation like i get so pissed off
with some of these jrpg games like
sometimes actual chain does this well
where you it's literally
the
same avatar with a different shade and
no nothing's really changing for the
other ethnicities they gotta work on
that because other than that and maybe a
couple little minor things this game is
amazing
this is a mmo vr mmo thinking
breath of the wild mmo meets fantasy
star sci-fi
you can literally climb anything
you could fly
you got classes they got um what you
call it like a melee double sword class
they got the man for heart bro
mad people can join yeah
it's destiny with the with the thing
they got public events they got but it's
a it's i would say the story is so far
but it's one of these worlds when you
look at it you're like oh i would
whoever designed this is amazing this
expansive they got cities it is seamless
and apparently there's a small team
that's doing this it's cross play with
oculus playstation vr steam vr um
yo they got it bro like literally when i
climbed the mountain jumped off and
started gliding and fly and you put your
with the with the joint you put your
hands back like what's that the naruto
joint addicts i love this game
because it's it's it's good
okay so you're good on all that but at
the end of the day at the end of the day
i'm telling you right i can't play
something like that in vr i'd get a
headache bro combat see i usually have
issues with y'all with combat and
shooting yeah me too combat is tight you
know what i'm saying you could block
dude like it is it's it they got one the
foundation is there if they stick they
got cooking in the game they got like it
is like monster hunter
it's bigger than monsters the monster
hunter is
like once the hunter world is huge um it
has that has that ability with the
glider and stuff like that um and
cooking what yeah
check it out it's true open world mmo
vr
and i'm not gonna the art style is
really cool man and the enemies look
cool everything everything look like
it's just you gotta check it out how do
they handle like movement and tethering
and all that all right so the movement
is you could they got the comfort
options for the guys that just want to
sit down and don't want to do no
standing you got that you could just
move around like a first person you
could control every aspect if you have
broken sickness to turn it and all that
stuff if you don't like that they got
the teleport system for the guys that
have motion sickness or whatever who you
don't want to do the quick movie because
some people that really affects them but
they got it yeah motion sickness is bad
yeah
now they got free but i tried that in
resident evil and that didn't even
really help me there either like i just
i don't like like the weird 45 degree
turns like right
what i like about all of them and this
one is they have every option on the
turning
can be tweaked everything can do like
they are literally catering to anybody
with any type of motivation but anyway
you do vr
i i have a playstation vr um but yeah i
haven't played that in a long time to be
honest next
the game
yeah i didn't have a proper pc to handle
vr properly
and now that i upgraded my rig actually
i'm i'm thinking about getting an oculus
okay
i mean
cog definitely um you know open eyes to
a lot of things i mean i was in er early
the playstation vr the tethering thing
uh stopped me but i mean this aspect
once i hear that everybody can play yes
see i definitely wanted christopher hart
to use his vr more so
what what i want to do i definitely want
to play zenith but when i saw y'all say
xenips i'm like
is ramen vr but yeah check it out it's
called for those who missed the name
xenith the last city it just came out
this week again on oculus psvr quest vr
hey full cross play and you can play
with the whole they got guilds they got
clans they got everything
we gotta get rock on we'll talk about it
but anyway so we got all that salt let's
all pay the bills and then we got this
uh patient guest that's been waiting for
us no doubt so let's get these super
chats that we have up until now
let's do this we have dono taco five
dollar super chat have the lord tried
zenith vr yet i played a bit yesterday
and it's pretty cool a good vr mmo is
something i've been looking forward to
yes yeah look at that perfect time
perfect perfect tap
then we got wandering dutch 10 pound
super chat shout out to brother boxing
burger representing of course have a
great show all here comes 5k no doubt
shout out to our iop brothers for
showcasing greatness thank you my god
dutch man salute the dutch brother
then we have flame ten dollars if we
chat good at good afternoon fellas i was
gonna make a comment about respawn being
better than 343 for having over double
the numbers of infinite with uh numbers
then infinite with apex and half the
time but we have a guess so i can't oh
wait
[Laughter]
come on
flame pragmatic eagle with the 50 super
chat thank you sir good afternoon lords
ladies and fellow gamers it's the lord's
day and time for the best podcast out
there thank you so much
lords addict sovereign king cognito and
today's guest boxing burger the realm is
ready for another great episode let's go
yeah
then we have boonty five dollar super
chat the original don dada
let's go
i love doing that
then we got bruno ramos diaz let's put
the crest in the chat for bruno ramos
diaz yes welcome to the realm sir thank
you so much
then we got creeper evox five dollar
super chat
style ps5 looking like a coal miner up
in there yeah it did bro
i'm sorry i'm sorry but like i said
february's gonna be lit
see seafood next week i'm happy
eight hours and then it's gonna get shut
back down into september
we got horizon we got horizon more than
eight hours
here we got raiden blade remember for 12
months thank you sir lord bronze saab is
joining king now only the disc version
is playable those poor digital owners
record of lotus war sega sega kids happy
days golden days yes
i was i was one of those man
you go into deep rabbit holes when it
comes to like obscure dreamcast games
yeah really good stuff yes sir
we have always cola five dollars super
chat
pace
baby
first the mcu and
now the ilp you always bringing great
characters together can't wait for the
next six hour iopu
no no no no no no
once a lifetime generational moment
exactly remember remember that moment
remember it well cherish it
another eight years and then we get to
it like the mcu yeah exactly exactly
exactly then we got doobie two dollars
for chat hit that like ilp fan thank you
my brother yeah let's hit that like
button
subscribe my channel
[Music]
popped in here we have big cloud gaming
five dollar super chat salute to my
brother shout out to you sir
what up
then we got flame once again two dollar
super chat give me credit i haven't been
messy in weeks that is not true sir but
that's fine
we'll give you that ability to be uh
messy today please do so
nobody's taking it away from you that's
true
then we have
chinese two dollars super chat salute to
the lords on the snowy sunday yes yes
yes
east coast northeastern man we shoveling
all day all day right some of the snow
over we are missing snow here oh my
goodness you can have it all you can
have it all
for free
pragmatic eagle earlier right yeah
cool cool no doubt everything caught up
yes sir all right one last for me shout
out to michy pooh
that black mug he said he showed his
appreciation for all the entertaining
and thoughtful discussion as an og xbox
gamer i was increasingly becoming
distant from gaming i appreciate you all
and game pass laugh out loud for
reigniting my passion and introducing me
to other creators salute oh that's
what's up and then someone else didn't
put his name he got that uh 10k t people
still trying to sneak that in i see
just scored it congrats iop on twitter
we got to take that down yeah speak to
him
get down talk to schwab get that off
shout out to ace in the chat we are not
doing six and a half hours i see you
stop it and now um shout out to another
anonymous user he got that little man
die cut sticker all right yeah got the
stickers i would see people counting the
stickers that's what's up little man
that dude put this sticker on his little
honest little man yesterday seriously
yeah wow
it was on twitter yesterday i forgot who
it was oh tag me i did not see that
for doing that
it was i was like oh that's so cute
you know what i think i gotta get a
little man to put him on my pc just to
look at him because
yo microsoft
what's up
oh
what's up doctor like little man should
definitely be inside uh what's that game
they got uh which one that we that
cartoon game that that that's inspired
by you know little man oh like cuphead
no laughs
yeah yeah how about that
yeah he's from that era yeah he's from
there
yeah we can use them in black and white
let's talk to me
so i'm gonna get the last two that we
gotta get uh boxing burger going on a
second okay so we have don't know taku
ten dollars will be checked i want to
call fraud alert on the lords for not
having an entire segment dedicated to
the return of the dreamcast classic kyle
the kangaroo that's right
give me your sega badge yeah they they
are it's not a remake it's supposed to
be like a sequel to cow the kangaroo i
saw the uh release trailer yesterday i'm
gonna say no sir yeah
i mean i'd rather shout out to cow
i'd rather i'd rather pick my eyes out
than have that oh my god
jesus keep him in black
hollywood keep him with the blair witch
project
[Laughter]
yeah we got hollywood rules five dollar
super chat songs ps5 needs lotion on
them dry elbows addicting black and
white over there in the mirror dimension
yeah my ps5 definitely needed some
palmer's
then we got gaby forte five dollars
super chat great to see boxing burger in
the realm let's pray that jimmy g
doesn't throw the game away today
don't jinx it don't fix it and as always
hey king boo boo hey forte
[Laughter]
are we done
all right so now that we got all the
business all the stuff
done and what the laws have been planned
we've got to focus on lord boxing burger
his video game system history his
journey into content creation and
podcasting and of course what led him to
those outstanding videos on the boxing
burger youtube channel solo boxing
burger let's start from the very
beginning what were some of the first
video game systems you had and what got
you into gaming
well
we have to go way back um my father had
an atari that was probably the first
video game system i played on but i also
remember him not being too happy when my
brother and i played on that
probably because we were too young i
don't know so i always say my first uh
actual video game system was the og
gameboy that is where it all started my
mother got that uh to me for my birthday
uh i remember that all too well in 1990
and um
just the christmas after that i got the
nes and from there on out um
yeah i had almost every every system
released
okay and what area are you living in
because in germany south germany south
of germany yeah all right okay so you're
in germany um nintendo was heavy there
was it no sega
sega was literally not existing
they made the exact same uh
mistake in my opinion like xbox did up
until a couple of years ago they simply
didn't advertise their system at all wow
my brother and i we gotta we we had the
sega systems but to this day it's it's
really funny to this day i i
outside of my twitter world and youtube
world i don't know anyone um who had a
sega system wow i was the only kid at
school who had a sega as well as a
nintendo
but it kind that kind of was hard
because you never had someone to talk
about the games you never had the chance
to trade your games you know in the
genesis mega drive days um when we were
your kid at school you usually traded
games on the school yard with the
nintendo games but i i was not able to
do that with my sega games so
um that's why i definitely grew up on
nintendo more than i did on on sega let
me ask you let me ask you one quick
question before you look at this is very
interesting so in in germany in that in
region was it the system the console was
available was it or was it not available
was it available and it just did not it
was available
at all yeah it was available but it was
literally not evidence wow that's crazy
they just did a product dump with no
advertising no advertising exactly what
xbox did uh many many years later
and they didn't change that up until the
middle of the the xbox one generation to
be honest wow wow
because i noticed when you said game boy
and then you went to nes i was like uh
so you know because the parents is
formed by when they go inside the store
so
and if you see advertisements and area
and stuff like that and
all parents want to get the most popular
thing for their kid usually you know but
you know so i guess if they don't see no
advertisement for sega then yeah like
what the hell is that
the thing
the sega was actually a quite funny
thing um i remember that i was like 11
or 12 years old when he got the first
time sega system in the house and
um i i got that because i was um on a
schooling exchange in the uk um we were
for one week uh
our entire class was visiting um
families in the uk that we had a
partnership with from school and i was
there and and the kid i lived where i
lived for one week um he had a sega
that's what introduced me to the sega
wow and then when i came back i wanted
it for christmas and that's how i got it
so shout out to the exchange program
they gave you a whole loop
what was it like did you play uh uh
golden axe what what did you play yeah
what was the gatorade
i played goldbacks um of course the
sonic games and so on um
there was a
batman game on the oh
i don't remember the full name of it i
love that that is that is the the one
that i remember the most to be honest
yeah yeah okay that's what's up that's
just the only only one person that had a
segment
oh you you and boxing burger are the
same
yeah i only knew that first
in that regard we definitely are no and
then later when i had i was already a
little bit older when the when the uh
dreamcast came out i really enjoyed that
i stood this day i still think this this
console was so far ahead of it
for sure
skies of acadia were awesome and so on
well i really enjoyed
what was the console that you purchased
with your money
i want to say the n64 was the first that
i purchased with my own money okay
okay okay don't judge him king fix your
face no no i'm not saying you know what
listen
it was no it was definitely
it's interesting but i'm trying to take
in the whole religion where he's in
right this is your face
and i think nintendo had like a
stranglehold on the region yeah so
other people weren't able to actually
you know come in and so i mean it forms
his opinion but
there's nothing wrong with that you know
you're right
no you're right but what nintendo did so
well is localization um
they really nailed that and um
especially if your target audience and
let's be real back in the time video
games were made for kids mainly yeah um
the
that the adult game was like we are
didn't exist that much back in the time
and they really nailed the localization
thing uh
and and that is what brings you in as a
gamer if there's no location that
is first xbox was really not successful
here because the localization xbox still
has issues with that still has issues
with it yeah still
absolutely especially uh in smaller
countries across europe i know in india
that localization is very poor in the
asian region it's also not that good so
um yeah and nintendo nailed it and i
remember all too well when the
playstation came out um
i was introduced to playstation through
the best friend of mine he got it um
and i remember we were i want to say 13
14. our english wasn't that good to be
honest and everything was in english um
all games were in english and and it was
really hard for us to play resident evil
wow
you have no idea what's going on going
on literally with the dictionary we sat
next to the tv and playing that game um
that that was hard uh but sony also
learned that really quick and they
improved
very very quickly in their localization
efforts um and that was how what what
made them so successful then over here
yeah this is i mean to this day um
playstation is the brand over here the
last generation they outsold
um xbox five to one wow wow i would
believe so yeah no it's it's very
interesting i'm glad we get in this
perspective that everybody's teasing
king king makes a good point because
it's like you know we forget because
we're technically you know the home
region for xbox so to speak you know i'm
saying or whatever but you forget in
other countries
that's such a disconnect could you
imagine playing a game
and it's like all in another language
here and we have to deal with that for
the rest of our life like it's in
another leg we don't understand really
what's going on that you don't say the
transgender song you're about to say
something translation no no no no okay
that happened a lot oh i'm sorry
when we would import games yes oh yeah i
would get japanese games and my mother
thought i was from savant that's a lot
um i was playing final fantasy and it
was all in japanese so i had to learn by
a lot of trial and error and writing
stuff down and due diligence so i
understand your frustration with that
part and then i had to wait for the game
to come out but
i understand
that that must have been microsoft's
arrogance
uh to think that english is uh spoken or
read throughout the world right where i
don't even think it was their arrogance
i think it was just them like you know
being realistic of what they can expand
within a certain amount of time yeah i
don't i don't think so because i'm gonna
say this part
i think
uh sony used nintendo's blueprint right
nintendo being a eastern company
understood localization was key
right because uh japanese and chinese
and stuff like that isn't spoken across
the world so obviously we most localize
these games to these regions that we're
targeting right and sony being from that
same home base looked at that formula
and said this is key for this because
you said nintendo at that period of time
outsold sega in that area because of
localization and stuff like that and
then along comes sony and does the same
thing to xbox and i think that has
something to do with the fact that their
native tongue
excuse me is not spoken across the world
so they understand localization is
priority
and when that stuff does happen and when
you're able to get an import game or
whatever and you see
you can go down and put the text in
german and you can go down that i mean
that that lends a lot and those games
get sold and that means that they're
looking at the region as something
that's important and i really think
nintendo took that as a priority that's
why i think that the 64 was your console
that you persecuted your money because
you understood that all the games that
you were going to get was going to be in
your native tongue yeah that's just my
opinion i'm just listening to it i'm
like wow
what's funny is it like when it comes to
like localization and making sure you
know it's in everyone's language that
wants to play it like anime has like
this giant war going on constantly on
who want if if like watch something and
dubbed or something
it is just like
like literally there's anime people that
says if you watch something sub you're
not watching anime it is like they know
they're they're hardcore about it like
they really are and and if you get bored
go on youtube and typed in different
localization uh voices and it's crazy
the different tone and how different
people sound when
they'll take like an emotional scene
and they'll have like a perspective of
like
everyone that's ever done that scene
like
it's crazy if you listen to like
different because obviously it's
different actors like not one actress
speaking all those different languages
so it's it's interesting to see how like
the different tone of people across the
world would do oh yeah
that's right and especially with humor
uh yeah it's sometimes really difficult
to play yeah because there's wordplay
yeah
what i wanted to shut up if i give it
right back to you boxer burger was just
that
like what king was saying in in
reference to you know we were doing the
whole job like getting final fantasy not
knowing what the hell is going on and
playing it and because it just goes to
show you the passion for the region to
still want the game right that they want
video games they love what's going on so
bad this looks so fire that i don't know
what's going on but i want to still play
it and i got a dictionary on the side or
whatever it is i'm trying like i gotta
salute you on that because that's a
passion right most people are not going
to go through that and they just throw
their hands up but salute you continue
on your journey you were saying so what
all with the sega stuff and then
obviously nintendo systems in the region
and then um yeah and after
after that period during probably during
the og xbox um
days ps2 days um i also was big on pc
because um yeah that's where the bigger
pc uh games were simply and
um
i i for a couple of years don't worry
you're still allowed to come back
he's master race atticus masturbate
no no as long as you're doing the
cheating stuff we accept your kind
you throwing them in the hacking
community already damn
yeah
those were the days um and then
like your limitations
continued yeah and then uh
i was already a young adult going to the
university and i lived in a shared
apartment um i had at the time um a
playstation 2
i had the
gamecube
and uh the wii wasn't out yet and
suddenly my roommate came home and he
had that little box with a with a big
axe on it
you remember that what
and um yeah
we have heard actually yeah there it was
this new game console
but it was nowhere to be found in stores
there was
zero reporting in magazines
and that was like i want to say
2003 or so so one or two years after the
the og game uh og xbox came out um
and he i decided i don't know where he
got it from but he came home and we
started to play halo
on that machine and um it was actually
that that was a funny night i i remember
that um
he he just had a new girlfriend and we
were playing for an hour or so uh halo
we were absolutely like oh that's
awesome he got i got a phone call and he
had to leave and we had
we know about that king used to get
those calls during halo we know about
that call okay i broke up with a lot of
girlfriends yeah continue so what
happened so the call came in with your
beard your man had to leave the halo
session so then what happened yeah
and then i i've played the entire night
solo uh till the next morning and he
came back from it from his new
girlfriend and we're still playing i was
almost done with halo then by then and
it
was awesome yeah and from there on out i
wanted to actually to buy that uh then
uh a an xbox myself i went to a into a
game stop here in germany and the the
guy working there asked me what's an
xbox
so wow that was really this just tells
you how poor it was advertised here over
here i i got one eventually um
and um
and and then i started to play morrowind
uh on the og xbox and i remember that
that was the the game that brought me
over from pc as my main platform and
yeah um because i said what's the first
time i had really the experience okay i
can get everything i can get on pc the
same experience with shooters like halo
and rpg's like like morrowind so i have
a question i have a question right
because uh all right so you said that he
was playing nintendo and stuff like that
and you went over to pc and and your pc
experience is probably first person
shooters very deep rpgs like kingsfield
and stuff like that
um rpgs
and then you got a chance to taste the
xbox pulse and you got a chance of a
first person shooter that was probably
one of the most successful first person
shooters on a console right so you're
able to get that first person feel
without a giant keyboard and mouse you
have the control in your hand but
morrowind
that's morrowind that experience with a
real deep rpg in a very big open world
yeah that that that kind of changed and
opened your eyes that because you know
coming from and you know microsoft was
known as like this pc company
yeah did did that just start forming
your whole thought pattern behind
microsoft's identity because it wasn't
uh advertised over there what was your
identity with microsoft at that point
what did you think about them at that
point i i i
it's a good question i i didn't have
special feelings i know they were the
the some guys oh
windows is so awful and i don't know i
never was
that wasn't me i just yeah it is
microsoft okay microsoft is getting into
gaming interesting i didn't really think
a lot about it um for me it was just
another console and then i i i really
enjoyed it because it offered something
different and then
just a couple of months later uh xbox
live was launched and you could also get
that online experience now on a console
that was simply new yeah we didn't have
that before um i
like you said the the typical pc
experience is where stuff like
first-person shooters of course but also
stuff like diablo 2. i played that
starcraft warcraft stuff like that yeah
um these kind of not games and and
suddenly you were able to play online
and
opened up a lot of things for me um
especially uh because the community in
germany the xbox community was so small
i suddenly got to know a lot of people
i've never met before yeah that was
what's new to me to be honest because on
pc i was playing with my friends from
school from the university whatever
right um
but
yeah but with that i learned that there
is this this online community yeah and
that that was brand new to me and
it was a super special experience i want
to ask you a question about that because
you you actually sparked my mind on
something in reference to that because
you know we forget at the time so i've
like there was you know the xbox came
out it was it was a very powerful the
ogx box was a very powerful machine for
his with time with the hard drive with
the ethernet and all that stuff in and
comparable for pc at at the time right
so my thing was like now xbox live comes
out and you hear boxing burger talk
about how it opened them up as far as to
other people so with i guess my question
to you boxer burger is that
in the pc realm when you were doing your
gaming online was it more so just
locally with people in germany and
people that you knew and was it that
xbox live kind of expanded you
internationally with a group of gamers
that you probably would have never come
across was that why the affinity for the
brand and and and online gaming even
kind of was more you were more
enthusiastic about it at that point
absolutely absolutely that was
a game changer for me um just to simply
to meet people um that that you didn't
know and then you got i remember then
exchanging um the icq numbers you know
yeah
and then you better you met someone
online on in halo and and the next day
you were chatting with him in isaac you
and it was something yeah
i was just gonna say i get there's a lot
of like toxicity especially in the 360
era
but i i do feel like
the the positivity that that console
gave in terms of like online
connectivity
was worth that yeah nonsense people had
to do it because
guess how fast
and it was just the fact like when he
says about you know
on the pc was really really really the
wild west back then like if you were
it didn't matter yeah but it is
but back then i mean like it was really
like you could not get into any sort of
online game it sounds like world of war
with the cheating you really can't
either oh my god oh my god he's on a
crusade crusade
today i'm just saying
back then like it was really there was
nothing in place to protect anybody from
any right anybody no you're right
at the very least the xbox it gave you
the wall garden to be like okay
at least you hang out with these racists
the isolated racist of it
he's right but some of my best games
that i played with was some with some of
the most racist people right no no no
because it's listen and i've met people
it's an opportunity to teach people yes
a whole lot from my little black i i got
a little black friend right and you know
his name is david
right until they see you
and when we play call of duty oh they
invite me over right so oh this is my
friend david but then they add me and
they're like wow you know
news depicts a certain that's true
right so at the same time i i really
didn't have friends from this place or
that place but when i started getting
friends from like germany yeah or or or
different parts of europe and i'm asking
questions okay what's going on over
there i know what you mean
xbox
bridge the gap that normally yeah you
don't get the chance to have a
conversation
and even on pc like if i i wasn't
educated enough to have a a a microphone
and a headset and all that other stuff
when i was playing it'd be a lot of text
right
so microsoft broke that barrier down
that everybody got a mic in a box yes so
everybody was talking so
when you when you start learning things
and meeting different peoples and
understanding different cultures i
thought that was amazing i agree you
bringing that part up that they you know
they broke down a wall garden in an
aspect of vocabulary and speech and
meeting people because we're buried off
from people completely now that that
whole access is accessible to you now
and that's a beautiful thing to hear you
say that that changed a lot of things
for you that's beautiful yeah what i
wanted to add real quick was that i
agree with you it says that for me it
was
hearing
a different accent than mine yes and i'm
like because you was like hold on where
are you from they like yo i'm in
australia man i'm like what like y'all
talking to someone did you
like when you have a positive experience
online and then you add that person to
your friends list like the first couple
of people you added it was a big deal
and those were your yours or your
brothers your sisters in that game and
it was so cool to be like yo i am
literally playing with someone that in a
region that i've never been never
visited sounds completely different
different culture you know aspect and
the last part i want to say is that um
which which boxing burger uh talked
about eloquently is that when we talk
about the pc the thing that xbox live
doesn't get enough credit for is that
unified party chat system across all
games right yep that's big because what
would happen is we would see is each
community in the past had its own
separate you had to be online in that
game with the friend list specific to
that game right but you that didn't
travel so gaming addict lord attic
traveled with me on xbox live through
all that's the thing that people don't
give it enough credit for and it was it
was a game changer to hear what your
problem was what was your game attack
yeah it was the game yeah yeah
you don't even want to answer it
what was it
it was master boxy um master boxing
my first my first xbox account um
actually got locked by xbox i want to
say into 12 years ago at the very end of
the 360 era because back in the time um
in germany we had
very strong regulations when it comes to
violence and games and especially in
wolfenstein um you know there's this
nazi symbol what's the interesting thing
yeah
you're not allowed to use that in
entertainment um media so no movies
whatever um can depict that symbol so
they always censor that out and i
changed the region to uk to buy
um i it was either wolfenstein
yeah and i bought that and that was not
allowed and that's why they locked my um
wow
so when you go to my profile it's like
12. it was yeah it was returned to
castle wolfenstein that was uh yeah open
world wolfenstein they yeah they they
would not have before we give it to
attic boxer give me that correct german
pronunciation i love what he says
again i just had to eat it
it kind of reminds me of like um when i
would want to play
like there there there's a game called
lost odyssey i'm a huge fan of
and um
on my older gamer tag i remember that
i was having
i was having a lot time getting a deal
uh to getting an achievement and i and
i'm just getting destroyed i'm like i
still understand like why is everyone
had this but i don't so then i found out
that there was there's like a
there was an expansion that was only in
japan really like it was a free dlc that
gave you something that you had to be
there to get
so i was sitting there and i was talking
to my friend john and he's like yeah
he's like you know just let's roll
through that location inside from japan
well see i did it with like a different
account i didn't do it with like the
actual account i had yeah but yeah like
my old account i i got a japan account
just so i can download one dlc
to get to to get that that uh that
achievement that's what's up man this is
these are great stories i'd love to hear
this perspective okay continue boxing
breaking i got a couple more questions
for you
yeah sure um yeah i mean i think we
already covered the xbox journey but i i
want to mention i also had a time always
a playstation because it was simply the
system everyone had here in germany um
that is
when you wanted to play with your
friends or trade games with your friends
or whatever
playstation was the thing to have um
but i was always a little different yeah
i was the sega
later it was the xbox um
but yeah um and
so from there on out i and i also had
all the portable systems of course the
nintendo systems i still have every
system um i always say i think i bought
more than 40 different consoles
let me ask you a question did you did
you have a pc engine or turbo graphics
no i didn't have a turbo graphics so
was it in the region that's the real
question
that's a good question i don't know
honestly i really don't
what i realized only later when i was
way older is uh one
significant difference towards the us
and the uk were that we didn't have
arcades there were literally no arcades
in germany and sega was big in arcades
and that was
what what generated bread
obviously and it's dramatic
real quick to go back to go back to your
pc real quick
maybe i missed this what type of what
pcs that you have over there
like because obviously in europe you had
the tandies and stuff like that and you
had uh the the the zx spectrums and
stuff like that so what
what was like the the like the first pc
my first pc um was a 486.
um okay i had that and the first one i
built on my own was a pentium 100.
[Laughter]
when you wanted to build a pc back in
the days you really had no google or so
where you just could
learn how to do that i i literally had
to go with my best friend to the library
we rented books
on how to hear that
books in a library
yeah i mean that that's why i am in the
80s man you act like we don't have
internet here song what are you talking
about that's why you were straight
other times when you went straight
you're the multiverse
and actually that's where my love for
tech came from and later um that's why i
started studied um electric
engineering yeah
um let's get into it that's that's still
my my passion for technology came from
from those days um when we started to
build our own pcs and
um yeah yeah it's a little bit this is
great great gaming history
loving all these stories especially
localization all the stuff you talk
about and then just your your desire to
kind of be different right not just stay
in the box that everyone else is doing
but have that curiosity and satiate that
curiosity to go check out other things
which is kind of cool i don't know why
king's laughing
just stay in a boxing in my head that's
i just said paul
we got that but
hang on i want to say one of those
please because
one thing that like you said i always
wanted to check out what else is
available not just the one mainstream
product that everyone has
the thing really is and king spoke about
this um also
what xbox did is with this xbox live and
we talked about it i i got to know
people from around the world um
that
share this passion and that is
what really hooked me on gaming till
till this day is that gaming really
unifies yeah gamers across all yes from
all countries i mean look at us here
yeah i mean here in germany you guys
over there in the u.s
i was just the other day on a podcast
with someone from australia from india
gaming that is something that no other
entertainment art from can do pretty
people together like that and that is
that is what's so awesome about uh
gaming and that's that's where the
operation comes from it's incredible we
even got a time traveler from the 1800s
i don't know how poor you are to have a
black and white tv in the 80s
[Laughter]
i'm just helping you here no but it's
real bad
funny no it's real boxer burger and
that's why like i mean to me it's just
silly when i see the beefing
on gaming because i'm like i love it
though it's just so stupid to me like
it's just like bro like we are literally
unified because of this thing we share
and now you try to have but we divided
those yeah
but they try to have i got to say jokes
right but we don't have a real i don't
talk to that dude no more because of
this i find it i find it ignorant and
funny at the same time because
you know i'm i'm listening to your story
right and localization
made you get out a dictionary made you
learn
uh to to understand what you you what
your passion was because regardless of
what you was gonna figure it out right
yeah i did that with comic books yeah i
would sit there and when when my
teachers found out i was reading on a
college level and i was like in the
fifth great it was because i wanted to
know what these words meant so i would
get a dictionary i will sit there and i
will try to figure out things and
you also did that with your pc yeah
that's real you you wanted to play you
know stuff
it's such a passion
that you went
with and you actually engineered your
stuff so this tells you that nothing is
going to be a barrier for you you had
nintendo that was localized in your
region but sega wasn't and once you got
a taste of it you wanted that and you
wasn't going to be put in the box pause
like you know saab said i mean
cognito said
you have expanded xbox live has expanded
your reach i've also noticed with your
channel you have expanded so good
transition it's it's it's in it's in you
right it's in the person so when we
listen to people talk about oh um i
don't talk to you because you play yeah
i've never i've never understood that
mentality it's literally it literally
sounds like this cognito you play
playstation 4. it's on site yes
but it's a closed mind and open-minded
individuals don't share that same aspect
of those things so we find it funny
where other people that's still like
their bible it's kind of weird but it's
it's just
opening up your mind to new experiences
and understanding there's a common
thread within these experiences yeah
yeah it's gaming that's another thing we
got you have a preference but there's
definitely a common thread someone's
gonna say something you know you guys
talking about xbox and stuff uh you know
address in the 80s has no idea what's
going on
perfect transition from addict at a
boxing worker um yeah man so like we
talked about that enthusiasm we talked
about you know that desire to get into
tech and then i want to talk about
content creation specifically you know
and like you know what were
kind of what was the drive behind that
and some of the early influences to say
you know what i want to make a channel i
want to get out there and say what i
have to say about gaming talk to me
about that yeah i mean um the the first
things that
or where it all started for me bro
were a lot of forums of course um that's
where you started like i don't know 15
years ago going online talking to people
like i said i was introduced through
xbox live to to
the possibility to i it didn't came to
my mind before that that i could just go
online and find people who share the
same passion than i do
and i was very big on a
specific german
forum um
the biggest xbox forum and i was the
user with most comments on there
and then um i
also found twitter and um suddenly i
i really can't remember why i started to
tweet in english because simply because
i was approached by so many people and
then i met people online and then i
started to tweet in english
and
yeah from there on out i found um a
couple of years ago three four years ago
boom mr boomstick actually
and he asked me um to come on his show
um and that was the first time i did a
podcast um
and a couple of people heard that and
was invited to other shows and so i was
podcasting for like two years or so one
and a half two years and then the
pandemic started oh no
and the day the the the um quarantine
was put in place for the entirety of
germany my company decided that we go on
unpaid leave and i was stuck at home for
like eight weeks
um
and
what better way to then uh or what
better way to to spend your time than to
start a youtube channel
i was thinking about it for a long time
to be honest a lot of people approached
me hey you have so such a strong opinion
why don't you do your own content um
and that's when i started so
uh second of march 2020
was the day yeah when i uploaded my
first video
and
um so almost two years ago um and yeah
at the beginning the first couple of
videos they were
horrible but then i and that is what
what really surprised me is um that a
lot of other content creators
actually approached me and and tried to
help me out and um
all kinds of people the bigger ones that
you know are definitely someone like
dealer yeah party chatting was running
me through a couple of things
um of course there was boom
cognito we also spoke yeah
and
that was really new to me i didn't think
of this i always thought oh they they
see me as a new competitor in the field
but that's really not it the the content
creator scene is such a welcoming scene
um and from there out i tried to learn
as quickly as i could um i tried to
improve um
everything from editing
um audio um recordings and so on how to
do that properly um and then i upgraded
step by step uh now yeah last just last
year i bought a proper rig with a 3080
and everything
you heard that 30 80 right so when you
go to figure out how much that costs
[Music]
you know what you know what i have to
say about that don't you just do his
faces on it
before you get somebody out there
before before you get into the uh the
other part where you improve boxing
burger i do want to give two people
their flowers that you mention you know
one is boom and the other one is dealer
and the reason why is that boom i always
feel his platform and we're definitely
thankful as well always giving new
voices a shot yeah right because it's
it's hard you know i'm saying you're
trying to get yourself known you have a
passion but like you know no one's
hearing you or no one's allowing you to
guest and you know stuff like that so
that and then i want to give um dealers
flowers a reference to
video production
and just how to take a channel to the
next level and people don't realize how
much behind the scene he's really helped
a lot of people
right and then what's funny is when
dealing with you dealing with both it's
funny to see how your journey has kind
of improved because i i remember not
because you're like i want to give you a
flowers like i remember i was like your
video quality was so good
i was like oh this is like the german
cody's
like it was so because there's bars to
it let's be honest there's levels to it
right and i always feel like you know
dealing those guys you know what you
call it call red all look like there's
levels you know what i'm saying and that
i remember when addict got there i was
like oh addict just stepped on this
video again like you don't say again we
got to give the flowers to also people
who are not hoarding information and
actually help it and then you see your
channel go but continue
yeah no you're absolutely right and they
all do it behind the scenes without
getting getting the compliments for it
yeah it's not like they go out on
twitter and brag about
this or this one just do it behind the
scenes and stay quiet about it and um
that's why i definitely want to
use this platform and say a big thank
you
for everyone who helped me understand
how influential deal is without looking
for praise yeah yeah
beautiful people that's a fact
absolutely absolutely and um
yeah
so uh i did that youtube
those youtube videos then for a good
year and suddenly i don't know what what
happened the the channel um
what was the video what was the first
video you know she was like yo
look at these views what happened here
like give me that first one
the first one was um i don't know
remember the exact title but it was
about um
the arden a2 features um there was a big
um interview with jason ronald back in
in 2020 no one knew jason reynolds yeah
there was an interview and no content
creator made a video about this but
there was a big interview and he
explained a little bit what is vrs what
is the velocity architecture and i made
a video about that it got like 10 000
views or something like that
um
and um that was the first one that
really
gave me like i don't know 4 500 subs
with one video is for a small channel
like me at the time it was that was
really awesome
and that was the big one and actually
that that inspired me to
to think about um
what can i do with the channel that to
differentiate myself a little bit at
least from what's out there
and um i noticed that a lot of people
talk about tech um but they either um
explain tech in in a way that's either
hard to understand or
they just say ah i don't know let's take
for instance mesh shaders or something
yeah that [ __ ] is going to be awesome
and they will make the games look
amazing and you know what i need you to
do
yeah i need you to make a tech for
dummy's channel and then give me that
sub channel like tell me where it's at
that way you know because sometimes i'd
be like i i'll be like watching tech
chat or something like dude i have no
idea
yeah
looks better yeah exactly and
either tech channels do that or they
just say oh the stuff is awesome and but
don't really explain why and that's what
i try to do with my channel now i i try
to explain
tech in in ways that people hopefully
can understand it um
just one example of two weeks ago i
uploaded a video on uh the hellblade 2
graphics um from that gameplay demo that
they showed at the game awards and i i
was not just explaining oh look it looks
awesome i tried to explain in hopefully
understandable words um how ninja theory
made this what is so special about the
graphics how you can see for instance
that parts of the velocity architecture
are used and i try to explain that in
in ways um that people hopefully
understand and um
that's the way how i try to
differentiate myself from a couple of
other of the tech focused channels um
nice yeah and i think you're doing a
great job
because i know a couple of times you
know we spoke on certain things and you
know early on and he sure i was on i'm
like boxing man show your face but then
he was like we gonna get to it we gotta
get to it yeah yeah yeah yeah we're
gonna get to it i do i do want to own
your shout out on that and and seeing
you know the journey there and the
growth i wanted to also talk about
obviously panelists for a couple of
podcasts right yeah i remember first
coming across here you know what was on
boom and then obviously i see more mid
midweek mix up shout out to dutch who
was in the chat early i was on i cast it
with you and stuff like that i'm like
wow this guy really knows his style is
very passionate about gaming and then um
you kind of jumped into the fray now
your own
world of gaming which you know some
i had a little influence
[Laughter]
i was tapped he was like i need to know
and i was like yeah you're the
international you don't say it makes
sense you know i get that so talk about
that and you know from from being a
panelist to a couple of podcasts and
then say now besides video because video
is one thing and doing that's one beast
in itself then they say okay now i want
to do host a podcast in the world of
gaming
yeah um i
i was approached by a couple of people
actually uh on twitter on youtube then
they they've seen me on other shows um
and they said why don't you do your own
podcast and it's simply a matter of time
doing the videos is actually quite time
consuming believe it or not it's not my
main job actually my main job it was the
reason why i wasn't able to
go on camera for a long time yeah um i
know we had the discussions yes
many discussions um
yeah uh there's simply a clause in my
work contract that says that i have to
get approved to be on camera um
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah and um so so i did that and then um
yeah i thought about okay what do i
really enjoy about content creation and
it's of course i'm having fun doing the
videos and explaining stuff and getting
in the into the comments and and
but it's it's a community it's the
people i interact with on a daily basis
on twitter and everywhere um on xbox we
play games um and so on and
the community aspect cannot be really
covered in the in um
in the 10 minute videos that you do yeah
and so i i thought okay
again how can i differentiate myself
with a podcast a little bit from what's
already out there and i decided to do a
small panel thing i only have one or
maximum two guests at the show um and i
want to make it a little bit shorter so
we only run like 60 to 90 minutes that's
depending on definitely not like that
the lord
[Laughter]
[Music]
it all has its pros and cons um but um
yeah i wanted to get uh
that out because yeah i think an hour 60
to 90 minute show let's say 90 minutes
can be squeezed in easier over the the
in your everyday life so
yeah that's what i wanted to do and um i
just started that a couple weeks ago um
we had the premiere the podcast is now
called the world of gaming um again i
think gaming is is something that
makes us happy all around the world and
there's so much that that everything has
to offer we talked about it prior to the
premiere yeah you gave me some advice um
on the naming and everything uh big
thank you to you uh for for all the
advice he gave me brother anytime so
yeah just after that uh it's it's going
well um my second episode already hit
more than a thousand views which is
awesome for such a channel like mine and
yeah i'm not closing in on 5 000 subs um
200 subs away from the 5k so oh we
almost
we almost there okay yeah we're almost
there we're almost there so yeah that's
that's that's why i'm pretty happy with
the channel right now and how
everything's going and i got a couple of
other plans for the rest of the year so
yeah exciting times and i i i learned
that uh content creation it just became
the same hobby like gaming itself yeah
talking about games and
discussing everything with the community
is what what i really enjoy and um yeah
so gaming and making content about it is
put your channel in the chat so people
don't know we got to get you to that 5k
right quick you know what's going on so
boxing boxing i have a i have a request
directly from xbox live from one of my
uh one of my father
our followers his name is cbec23 and he
asks
soft can you ask boxenberger to
correctly pronounce herzog's weak
hair suck what
the the old sega uh rts game called uh
herzegovina
and it's and zwie is z-w-e-i
so how would you say that hurt song
yeah we got to get them off with that
because you know the realm be asking but
um yeah man i definitely want to
transition again salute to you on that i
love the growth there
you're expanding more people are known
and again i want to give you your
flowers of reference to what you talked
about earlier which was you know kind of
putting yourself out there you know and
you had a legit reason it wasn't like yo
you was scared to do anything it was
just like hey my job i got what i'm
saying but there is i still want to give
you credit because there's still a
fearlessness to it and i feel like you
know once that happens you know there's
a there's a better connecting king
taught us that to be honest because i
was resistant for a long time almost all
the laundry was resisted shout out to
bone in the chat he was like i remember
listening to iop and only kingdoms on
camera at one point and that was very
true so shout out to paul i think that
is very important to engage and connect
with your community
absolutely uh for the simple fact
i view things by my own lens right so
you're looking at a avatar beeping
i don't get no emotion
i don't get if you're engaged
i don't get if you
decided to wash and clean up for that
and respect my time you know because
everybody that's in that chat
we have to respect their time respect in
our time so i'm trying to give back to
them the same way they're giving back to
us right
and
i think
camera
see you won't get the stupidity that i
do
camera right because let's let's let's
keep it real a lot of times i'm doing
ignorant funny stuff and
i want to be as visible as possible for
you to can get this
because when you tell your friend listen
this fool did the wildest thing that
i've ever seen and either you love me or
you hate me you have to do this you have
to see it yes right and i don't care
if if i make a fool of myself because
some people take this stuff way too
seriously yeah
and i don't we we are talking about
games
and only the people that make the games
that invest serious money into these
games
should be
on pins and needles we play we talk
about and we enjoy so why everything
shouldn't be fun and light-hearted right
and i think bringing that across through
camera because me and you spoke like
every show i was like yo what's up man
like with him and then like he's all his
camera is out but then we go live it'll
be like
yo what's going on
and i'm loving his content and i'm like
man oh man like if if this is a barrier
right and and i and i tell that to
everybody some people have whatever
reasons they do it that's their business
but
i know how i feel when i when i tune
into something and i i listen to the
people around me and they say the same
thing so it's
trust me and i'm looking in people's
background trust me i'm being nosey
every time all right i'm like if oh look
at the pictures on the wall or maybe
because i'm one of those individuals
that uh you know those voyeurs that want
to see what you're doing in the
background
what what did you place back there
you're admitting on on live that you
stalking people
no no i'm admitted online then i'm
gathering information for any time you
act
[Laughter]
i feel like that wouldn't go very well
if some cops pulled up to you what do
you mean you're gathering information
gathering information i'm an independent
contractor and the fact that if you act
up i will place your business out there
oh so so so you're blackmailing as well
as stuff yes yes sir
please write that down time oh
i'm right there
receipts are essential receipts
no i'm right there with you king i i
started to turn on the camera in
december so two months ago or so um
i love approval and um
yeah it's it's totally different to be
on a podcast and like you said we got to
respect the time that people um
take out of their busy schedule to
listen to us to watch our content
whatever and um
it it
just provides a better connection like
you said you can see okay
what's the guide looking like what's
his emotions is he falling asleep while
talking you're actually passionate
um yeah um i also by the way look at
the background yeah
people have cares it's true here on the
wall i i have a couple of canvases
hanging from screenshots that i take the
most beautiful shots i take i print them
on canvas and hang in there and then of
course i'll rotate
so yeah absolutely so are you one of
those people since you said you take
screenshots because i've noticed this
like a lot with the people that was
doing red dead 2
the world is beautiful absolutely and
and some people will take screen shots
and get certain angles and really fall
in love with the shot that and forza and
gran turismo and take pictures of these
shots and so you actually print them out
and post them up
yeah
exactly i print them on print them on
canvas and then i put them on the wall
and then i rotate them yeah that's
beautiful that's what's up brother yeah
better find a couple of questions before
we move on um the ground wants me to ask
lord boxing burger what's this thing
about plasma grenades that keeps coming
up i keep hearing plasma asking about
plasma so let's talk about that uh it
kind of became a joke in the in the
community because i um i made a video
about um
halo halo infinite and i i used the
phrasing like there's nothing like
sticking a blast macro innate someone's
up someone's bottom or something like
that
that vocab community thing and uh
especially sean who is a chat he's yes
heavily advertising yes last grenade so
that was one all right so we got that
the two um the science behind the name
you know the boxer bear boxing burgers
and is archimedes
retired forever because that's what you
were first known that's how i came here
yeah okay yeah
the the thing was um
[Music]
when i created my accounts uh archimedes
was basically taking everywhere
so i used boxenberger which is actually
a nickname um of my in real life yeah
yeah
what is it what is it what is the
nickname
yeah it's it's um it's a not an
abbreviation it's a d no what's the
english word
an acronym an acronym of my last name
my last name is box burger but it's it
sounds kind of similar okay i got you
so yeah and that's why it's actually my
nickname in real life
so okay oh yeah my friends call me boxy
or boxenberger
and um so i use that as my ad yeah in
twitter it always has been and i had to
name because the channel name archimedes
was taken i i also named the youtube
channel um
archimedes box better than yeah um i
didn't really think it through to be
honest at the beginning and it was i
just got to know people got to know me
as archimedes um out there the gaming
scientist because that's what i was
known in the forums
since i'm a scientist in real life
that was a was something um
that i used as a
in forums and so
i really didn't think it through but
then when the channel got a little bit
bigger i was approached okay listen i
can't find the channel under archimedes
um
yeah and then i said okay because it's
boxenburger and then i i i started to
unify the entire thing to make it easier
just for discoverability and uh brand
recognition basically and that's why i
ditched the archimedes and just used the
boxenberg and everywhere hello hello
love the history love the names love
what you're doing in the space and just
that trajectory brother it's really cool
to see you man so we gotta ask the final
question that we ask all the guests in
the realm
i need lord boxenberger's top five video
games or franchises of all time
so the top five
could easily name six because now i have
to throw one out there's one game um i
would i always bring up from the super
nintendo area which is a era which was a
secret of evermore i don't know whether
anyone remembers oh yes
yeah i love that game yeah that's
definitely one um ocarina of time
and i yeah i always read that one
right that redemption one solve do we
approve
oh he's clapping muted but he's best
he's clapping i'm not moving okay okay
you didn't hear that no now we hear it
now here okay good
um the witcher 3 definitely
uh
and now it kind of becomes hard because
i want to want to say arkham city and
skyrim um so
i have to throw one out i'll leave those
up to you so those are my six okay okay
okay
respect and of course we're gonna throw
arkham out
damn
so disrespectful sorry to batman that's
not about it i mean it's a great game
but skyrim come on man akhem got to hit
the bushes
arkham city really really did it for me
so yeah it's kind of hard
yeah
it's up to you to make the choice who
gets thrown in the bush
it's really really hard but i probably i
would remove akin then because um yeah
skyrim is something i still play i don't
know why but when they released that uh
anniversary edition a couple of months
ago i went back and i just felt at home
i put hundreds of hours into that game
i owned it on everything um on the
switch and everything you can switch on
your refrigerator
on every platform and we are fools to
buy it every time
you say why you keep selling it because
you keep buying it
that was next to my god howard so that
was very good salute to you and last
final question all the uh favorite
console of all time for boxing burger
and why
that's also a tough one i mean there
were a couple of great ones um obviously
i hold the n64
this would be the first very very well
am i but i want to say 360. okay because
the 360 really
um
that was a generation like nothing else
that was a generation that established
uh the online gaming yeah yes we had it
on on the ogx box but yeah it really got
big during those days and there were so
many ips and franchises that were born
in that era
um that i still love and play and um
there there are so many incredible
memories with that system oh yeah um
so i i want to say the 360 great great
choice salute the lord boxing burger
amazing gaming history you know what i'm
saying and he's hanging out today so we
don't get throwing everybody out we get
to chill with them you know say do these
topics but um yeah man i was like why
are you gonna queue up the chats off you
want to get into the poll
yeah all right pause
yeah
no doubt no doubt
moving along
yeah so uh
we got um 700 people in the chat well
700 plus uh please share this out give
this out boxing burger just gave you his
whole history which was incredible from
the aspect of he is a genius so
from from early on until now and the
fact that his first console that he
purchased with his own cash was a 64. so
nintendo dude stand up because you don't
get that much level over here with the
105.
with the massive acquisition of
activision blizzard by microsoft which
outcome do you think is most likely to
occur in the future
the winner of the three-way ilp poll
with an absolutely dominating 81 percent
of the vote was microsoft's
acquisition is a positive step towards
activision blizzard work culture dorman
ips add more value to game pass group
coming in at second place at nine
percent only nine percent was the messy
lords i don't care i still desire to
talk about call of duty exclusivity
fatima
and his last place at clay desire
was of microsoft's consolidation of
multiple large studios feels
monopolistic and not good for the health
of the games industry shacks kick sucks
steve shout out to all the lords who
participated last week on lord addict
man the the realm thinks it's overall a
good thing what do you feel
i mean obviously that that that's facts
you know the future i don't
yeah obviously look well first off i
only know the past i don't know
[Laughter]
what what what is a what is an
activision blizzard what is that
i don't even know what blizzard is
i like sierra
that's what they want right
pong is nice
you agree with the people you think
people got it right
yeah yeah yeah definitely no doubt no
doubt let's get before we get into these
topics uh lord solve you all caught up
yeah let's get these super chats oh lord
boxenberger if you can check the zoom
chat so you can check on that
pronunciation that the world wants to to
properly you know
yeah that's pronounced yeah
now i know which one he er he meant it's
herzog's spine
oh give me that
one more time
love it love it
all right we have a silent cipher five
dollar super chat great to see boxing
burger in the realm this morning cheers
guys keep the great content coming
then we have pragmatic eagle member for
27 months shout out to you sir thank you
so many negative hate focus channels out
there bjor's boxing burgers approach is
refreshing i'm sure you'll see more
growth as more gamers tire of the
constant negativity on other channels
pretty much thank you
yeah i'm about to be negative soon
though
three five seven five dollars for chat
ask master boxing burger about the 70s
and 80s funk he keeps playing on the
channel and why it's giving life they're
feeling that background music music
what's up with that yeah
yeah i mean come on gaming is such a joy
it's it's it's such an awesome thing you
you gotta have the positive spirit there
and that's why i always try to use funky
good
good mood music so yeah absolutely
i respect that music aspect i respect it
respect it you thank you i'm gonna send
you to shades say i remember for 10
minutes
sage i subscribed to your channel boxing
burger what's funny is that boxing
burger reminds me a ton of my best
friend from back in first grade that's
all salute
thank you
ow what did your friend in first grade
do that was so important
they said it wasn't math they said it
was supposed to be meister get it right
solved oh meister i'm yeah that's what
they said
they wrote oh they wrote bastard they
wrote masteries
i copy paste it don't come
like that thank you
i would have said meister shout out to
autocorrect
[Laughter]
then we have sage once again throw
arkham out unless we acquire batman and
wb so that the only way arkham beats out
uh skyrim is
that we can do that though cause our
wallets is good
here we have hargie chidi member for
eight months thank you sir can we feel
it yet microsoft backing xbox is
playstation going to stay on top buy
zenimax uh activism blizzard king ub and
square next maybe king's right no ps6
either way power dynamics changed
enthusiasm has shifted to xbox wow
a lot of different thoughts and what i
want y'all to just continue to watch the
videotape as we move forward
as we proceed
to give you what you need
[Laughter]
there we have reggie mobile nine five
dollars for chat great show as always
lords good to see boxing burger get some
shine let's get another six hours this
week no no
everybody been asking for that i mean
it's a it's a highly viewed show but you
got to understand only big
reverberations get something like that
yeah yeah it's about it
it's on the heels of my video yeah if we
get another six hours then that means
microsoft acquired somebody crazy or a
playstation got purchased by somebody
big
not that playstation purchased something
like that come on stop that we're gonna
talk about that
there we have split difference two
dollar super chat boxing burger broke my
heart man nothing from sega oh
no but you reached for the sake of
waiting
i guess i guess they they wanted it in
the top five oh oh oh okay because but i
mean
he went on a whole exchange program came
back and just went out and sold his
situation i mean i i was fine with that
dreamcast was in his
in his joints like come on man
absolutely
i would have to put a sega game in there
i would probably choose skies of acadia
beautiful yeah i love that game yeah
well done
and we have mads with the 10 pln i keep
forgetting what they mean matt shout out
to you sir great show i'm loving boxing
burgers gaming history oh yeah yeah i
need to be back on oh yeah marzipan
let's go yeah yeah yeah we haven't had
bonds in the ramen a while too yeah he
needed to be back on shout out to he was
in the world of games
yeah last week i watched it i watched it
shout out to vibes
germany salute
and we are caught up oh wow that was
great okay cool yeah so we gonna get
into it um king i believe you're up you
want me to set you up there sir set me
up now that's right you already know how
we do one two combo so um yeah man we
gotta talk about this uh strong q2
performance for microsoft xbox this was
king's topic obviously
[Laughter]
oh microsoft let's uh i want to quote my
man from the verge lord tom warren yeah
microsoft xbox series x and s consoles
have been on sale for a year they said
um overall gaming actually and microsoft
hardware revenue is up four percent and
microsoft's overall gaming revenue is up
eight percent after the company set a
record of 3.6 billion for the quarter um
and it's pr for the court in its
previous q1 2022 earned earnings xbox
content and services revenue also
increased 10 over the year microsoft
also revealed that in game pass has
grown at 25 million thanks to big
releases like halo infinite forza
horizon 5 and then they talked about the
um iconic but as the games added to the
service during their earning calls sacha
nadella revealed that more than 20
million people have played infinite halo
infinite making the biggest halo
launcher in history the dela also
revealed 18 million people have played
forza horizon 5 and then uh tom
finalized the article by saying
microsoft is now looking ahead to its
plan 68.7 billion acquisition of
activision blizzard
the purchase is expected to close fiscal
year 2023 and they said microsoft's huge
investment also means the company has
formed a dedicated microsoft gaming
division with phil spencer taking over
as ceo so
lord king this is your topic let's talk
about it let's talk about ceo phil
dominus maximus aurelius spencer
growth on top of growth on top of
expansions acquisitions and more growth
equals what to gain pass more growth so
i know you guys are sitting there saying
oh man but king you said it was 35 up in
that game pass all right so let's say 25
is actually solid subscriptions and for
you little one dollar dude
why are you blaming them
you know i listen i listen to people
talk about oh you know i can get game
pass for a dollar so why don't you have
it all right it's it's it's free stuff
y'all you're living off the free stuff
so why don't you have it
play games right so why don't you have
it but for you eight million dudes
that's down there for the trial
hope you stick around baby um because
acquisitions is crazy but i'm talking
about the level of growth microsoft has
seen you know since phil has been in
this position it's kind of crazy because
boxing burger express uh the 360 was a
seismic shift in his gaming uh a
landscape and i think that changed for a
lot of people right
so to up the ante and fulfilled to
become the all-time great which i've
seen uh in in in my lifetime i mean it
takes a lot to change that aspect of it
and i think these level of acquisitions
we saw the shift with xbox live which
changed things game pass is a game
changer right the same way as xbox live
is a game changer
financially boxenburger expressed that
uh for eight weeks he was off of uh his
job put them on unpaid leave
right so let's let's let's get that in
your head that's that's two months of
unpaid leave you're not purchasing any
games at that period of time because
you're just focusing on your essentials
of life right
your shelter your food and your family
right so you're worried about these
things but along comes this game pass
thing where you can you can shuffle out
at least 30 bucks for those two months
and actually have those entertainment
things put to the side right and and you
can still partake in what's currently
happening especially with date and date
is crazy
i'm looking at the level of growth and
these acquisitions meaning more games is
coming aside game pass uh more growth
and on and people are seeing the value
in the company
and it seems like the sky's the limit to
be honest with you what did y'all take
from and i must give a shout out to brad
sam's because
a lot of times i look at brad sam's
stuff and please if you're not
subscribed to brad's hair subscribe to
him because he gives you information on
a fiscal basis on a lot of things that's
going on in the industry in in in a
sense that's clean and honest to
understand so when i brought this to it
i brought it through brad sam's to be
honest with you guys because i watched
it and i was like wow
he delivered a a a fiscally a
responsible uh report
and and it showed to me that when you do
further digging
microsoft is in a healthy position to
change again
how we consume gaming because if you
notice they didn't talk about actual
purchase numbers of halo and forza they
talked about interactions right and how
do we interact nowadays because uh
netflix doesn't talk about purchase
numbers when it comes to your movies
you know which best buy and other people
were doing this is changing how we do
metrics
20 million eyes on your product changes
that 20 million 18 million eyes on your
product changes that so going forward
could we just get past oh we sold 18
million
wouldn't it be better if 100 million got
a chance to see your product
wouldn't it be better if 40 million got
a chance to see your product
and
doing services this level of commitment
microsoft has shown
satya and everybody is doubling down
yeah on making these acquisitions a
better prospect for gaming in general as
a whole as the the poll
revealed yeah what do y'all say about
this it's a lot of information a lot of
information and digest breakdown analyze
let's start with our esteemed guest lord
boxing burger what's your thoughts on
this um you know
second quarter news that kind of came
across online that i think microsoft is
supposed to report right as a song like
this this has to happen
yeah this is like yeah you can't hold on
to this fan you gotta so
because that was the question right
what's really going on so what's your
thoughts on all these different
numbers and things that's going on
microsoft
i mean it's great to see that they are
doing so well it's it's really
impressive i've seen a lot of people
talking
about how only 25 million subscribers or
only eight percent more hardware sales
cells uh and so on it's it's really
impressive if you think about it because
when you compare these numbers to the
last year to 2020 2020 was really the
year where the pandemic started and
gaming suddenly blew up out of the sky
everyone was at home everyone was
playing video games all consoles were
sold out everywhere
player base numbers went up and that
that was really unprecedented in 2021
the
pandemic yeah we still had it but
things got slowly back to normal um at
least to some degree and
microsoft still was able to grow
uh their ecosystem and it's um and that
is really impressive yeah that
especially that q2 of the fiscal year is
the last quarter of the of the calendar
year yeah when you compare that in 2020
we had the console launch yeah they were
still able to top that in hardware sales
good point this quarter which is really
impressive here
um
yeah so i'm i'm happy that they uh that
they see that growth because xbox has
been investing a lot they have been
providing a tremendous amount of value
when you enter that ecosystem and it's
not just the console ecosystem it's also
pc it's the cloud it's everything you
get
with that ecosystem and the value is
there people see that they see that they
have the games now they see that they
have quality products out there with the
consoles that they have choice and
options and
and that's why the ecosystem is growing
and that will allow microsoft to invest
even more and that's what where we
gamers benefit from so i'm happy to see
that this this was a success yeah good
points good points lord boxenberger lord
attic man um what's your thoughts i
don't know usually you don't really get
into the numbers too much but i just
wanted to get your overall vibe with you
know q2 for them and then obviously they
talked about the halo and forza
engagement what's your thoughts on all
of this
you mute it
you're definitely the other direction
that's cute they sell them more i want
to see games like i i don't i don't
particularly care about what they sell
and what they know i like that the
brand's doing well because that will
lead to maybe more investments into
other stuff more games
but at the end of the day it's it's cool
that halo success was cute i don't
really care
that's cute that's cute
but you know i want to see
my fable i want to see a vowel i want to
see
at the end of the day like
i want to see star field like i don't
care about how much
tommy tommy and kim got for christmas
like i just don't care
so let me ask you a question oh here we
go no no no no no no because this is a
discussion all right
i mean leading up to halo's launch it
was an unmitigated disaster since craig
right and the question surrounding halo
was was it going to be successful at any
point in time and when uh forza horizon
uh hit and it did 18 and people saw the
numbers going up well that cannibalized
uh the viewership on um halo and the
fact that halo has eclipsed
one of the most viewed games uh you know
i've i've heard of on a microsoft
platform in such a short period of time
my question is
it ain't just cute
what is it though he didn't say that i
actually do so no i know i know i'm just
obviously listen i gotta
i'm glad halo was successful i said i'm
glad halo 6 yeah guess what
halo is december's news i want january
i don't care what other people want i
want what i want but you want a halo
though
and i got halo and did you like it
yes but that's irrelevant to how many
they sold oh okay okay so you you just
only cared about the one person like
myself i've always only cared about the
one person
what are you acting like shout out to
addicts world make it it's all
triumphant return it's been it's been a
while at the end of the day i can be
you know i i can take a step back and
you know when they buy activision stuff
i didn't care about it but i understand
yeah i was bigger i was bigger
when it comes to forza horizon i'm not
the biggest racer fan but i understand
they need that look at this
stuff
i like that
i understand
at the end of the day
that's all cute
i want what i want
because what what my motives
that pres that pushed me to play games
well my motive is to push me to buy
games is what i want it's not what he
wants it's not what cognito wants is
that what saul wants it's what i want uh
i'm feeling it
tell him what you want though
what i want more than anything is i want
is i want my green light okay
okay he's gonna stay in that
multi-version
listen i'm gonna tell you again right go
to party city
google it go inside and then send it to
this iron bank
until then until then he's in out world
oh my god move it off move it up
solve man we got a filter
xbox q2 man how impressed not impressed
what you feeling what's your thoughts
it's impressive to get this i've seen
banter going back and forth about how
much money this is or whatever let's be
clear about something this is re this is
revenue completely overall revenue it's
not profit yeah but they're still in the
black everything
it's they it's they're making money and
they're growing that is the important
thing i see a lot of conjecture back and
forth though but it's not it's not these
numbers i'm like all right fine
but in no way
oh yeah i saw i saw i don't even know
it's just you know because you know
there's this there's needle threading
and there's
yeah oh i thought this was going to be
celebrated oh so they're still like this
is not important oh
no
he's going to get to a part and i'm
going to have to talk about that part
that he's getting to because i know
where he's break it down
i've been on twitter
okay so all right so everybody's whole
thing is um
what sony's gonna do to to to counteract
this right first of all let's be clear
you can't go to the store and go pick up
a playstation 5. you can't go in and
pick up a series x yeah you might be
able to find a series s but those soon
as those dudes hit the store
somebody's inside the store radio into
somebody yo we got little man up in here
you got to get them a bottle here
those those those things happen older
systems are selling at a rapid pace
let's be let's be clear about that xbox
uh 1x
i don't even see them but i see them on
ebay for crazy prices now
somebody said what that sony's looking
to purchase ea
okay
okay listen listen dudes
sony has a lot of debt right so when you
purchase companies you purchase their
debt as well when microsoft is
purchasing activision whatever debt act
division has
did they have to purchase their debt
do you have to go through what the cost
what the the company owes
and how much they're worth right
so when you saw them pay for bethesda
and you saw
oh they paid over market value no they
were purchasing debt as well to declare
them to to bring them in you don't want
to bring in dead weight when it comes in
you have to clear that debt because you
don't want that debt hitting your books
because what happens to you you go into
the red right you want to stay in the
black so when when sovereign said the
black that means you're being profitable
okay
sony has some odd trillion dollars in
debt not truly not trolling but they
have they're up there
when you do the math it is
at the same time at the same time
you know somebody put up their 16
billion over that yen uh there's 7
billion over that was the budget of
bethesda this is where the conversation
goes into now they can make smaller
purchases of companies like they did
with such a punch
and stuff like that and if you look at
the price line on it they purchased them
at a like a discount prices and you're
like wow
why microsoft buying these companies at
these prices they look at their debt i
got you at it and look at it and see if
it works for them and they acquire them
in that manner ea doesn't make any sense
for them to even think about purchasing
if they take a loan or going into that
stuff because they have to look at their
debt that doesn't make any sense so you
can kill that rumor there okay right now
capcom that makes sense look at the debt
remember capcom cleaned up a lot of
stuff so a lot of stuff aren't isn't
there
same thing with sega those companies
make sense for sony to do so but does
sony actually need to do that in this
area no because they're fixing up
different areas so financially we're
talking about a whole big company doing
different things two different companies
going in two different directions trying
to achieve two different things
don't try to poo poo what microsoft is
doing by saying oh well you know sony
needs to do this so like just the same
way i will honestly tell you i don't
ever believe microsoft should go into vr
if sony is in that space
certain companies don't need to do what
the other company is doing this is why
we purchase different consoles for
the different feelings that we get from
each console i have my sony stuff for
their stuff and i have my microsoft for
this stuff it would it would not be in
there
it wouldn't be that addict answered what
he was gonna say yeah you got your hand
up here here's my thing when it comes to
like buying the 2k or the ea or whatever
like
i do think that
shout out to colin uh he said a lot of
the only real
possible way sony could buy something
that big
is if they merged with them yeah so
yeah you know they i guess here's the
thing i don't see sony doing that like
by any means that look sony can buy a
lot of stuff but the thing is they got a
they got a a a huge brand they could
easily leverage that but the thing is is
the it's easy to go to your
you know to your your panel to the
people that are are going the money be
like yo i want to support cash money to
buy activision they're going to be a
little more open to doing that than than
sony going to their people and be like
yo we want to take out this loan and
that loan
it's a lot easier like it's it's not as
easy as just going out there could sony
possibly come up with the money i'm not
going to say they can't
but
the uh the odds of that happening is so
slow it's so slim so slim and then when
it comes to scoring this is not why buy
score enix like there's literally no
reason to buy square enix because
they already own all that pretty much
the majority of the games are exclusive
and i don't see a world where they get
to that point where they need those
where those games are not going to come
on their platform or not even be
exclusive so like that's my point is
it's just like look
i could see capcom but once again do
they really need capcom capcom's not
solving any issues the issue that they
have is the the
the possibility of the biggest
multiplayer and probably the most
multiplayer game that they have over
there with the war zone
and losing not necessarily just the game
possibly but losing the idea of being
able to market that game of the year
losing the idea of being the home of
playstation is call of duty yeah and
that's what they're losing and i don't
think capcom fixes that
capcom doesn't even remotely fix that
they need to start developing more
multiplayer focused games and that is
going to fix their issue long before
picking up a publisher that makes a
bunch of single-player games nothing i
mean they they make like monster hunter
and stuff like that but monster hunter
is not the same as losing call of duty
marketing rights and the ability to
market call of duty every year no i
would say yeah and it's a get itself is
useful no go ahead go ahead no i'm just
going to add on to what he said and give
it back to you which was that um
the the thing that i i think that when i
saw i was surprised that sony made this
statement after microsoft
required like i hope you know you're
going out you know hit them contracts
right you're gonna honor your contracts
right and to me i'm not gonna get into
the you know hyperbolic stuff but it
does show a concern that
they
bet on call of duty addressing their
multiplayer deficiency because let's be
honest first first party has been the
hashtag just one and they've been
comfortable in that pocket and in their
mind we'll buy marketing rights for a
destiny we'll buy marketing rights for a
call of duty we'll anything that's the
biggest multiplayer game we want that
brand association right so that's a part
of the deal that i did what i forgot to
mention last time during the second
pocket that it really affects them and
part of me not just you know again be
hyperbolic likes it because it's like as
much as i give xbox for hashtag just one
i'm giving them the same energy for
hashtag just two where i got your burger
where is your first point like i grew up
with the socoms you know what i'm saying
and then even they had king knows you
know the kill zones and the resistance
they would at least hey exactly they
would at least put their feet in there
right so what i'm hoping is now that
that safety net of throwing away the
money at the time exclusive or the
marketing is gone with call of duty
specifically maybe now they invest in
their multiplayer first party and then
we get more of a balanced portfolio from
that's what i would like to say boxer
burger you up what you got
yeah i just wanted to add real quick
it's just it's not just the multiplayer
games um it is also their concern about
ps plus because what what reason really
is there right now if you don't have a
call of duty anymore um
and um a couple of others like yeah you
mentioned destiny yeah um but um
yeah since their first party isn't uh
supporting any multiplayer player games
at the moment um
yeah what's the the point of ps plus for
a couple of or many subscribers of
course um
and that's what's something they also
have to rethink you know they have to
retake they have to repeat that's what
they have the pivot but i saw a
fellowship thing and i'll get my bars
off after you yeah i mean
i think i'm sorry attic i miss attic
sorry
i just have something really quick to
say yeah thank you like people that this
always happens when it's boxing yeah
it's always you i love you real quick
and then you could go and i won't talk
into the
topic but like
people need to realize that people like
all sony could have anticipated this
there's no realm where sony anticipated
microsoft buying activision like it's
one thing to buy bethesda that's why
sony really never said anything when
they bought bethesda if you remember
they didn't make any forms of tweets
we would hope you honored there was none
of that but yeah you're right you're
absolutely right and people was like oh
you you know i think that the contracts
you know the contracts probably have
something preventing them to come to
game pass et cetera et cetera that
contract was made in 2016 apparently
yeah
when they made that thing in 2016 do you
think sony's really think what happens
if microsoft buys activism no they won't
like like people need to realize that in
my personal opinion call of duty is huge
but that marketing's bigger than calling
the market call of duty goes up and down
yeah that marketing and the ability to
come out there on the super bowl sunday
or whatever the hell that is and the
ability to put at the end of that call
of duty commercial play playstation is
more important than the actual because
the casual fan we used to we know it
through the destiny days of our lives
they associate that brand they don't
know that that's on xbox as well you
know what i'm saying they just like oh
sony commercial call of duty on sony
that's how you get the account and
that's why it's this big and the fact
like you said this is an annual
franchise this is not something like
elder scrolls you're going to get one or
two fallout so they're like okay we can
eat that we can get one of those every
generation or four
yeah once a decade we'll miss that okay
you got that exclusive but now you're
taking that bread and butter what they
had plans for and and the word was there
was internal meetings there was like you
know i'm going to say cold red but yo
we're going to have to talk about what
our strategy moving forward in the
multiplayer space so i've continued we
interrupted man times and
i
then
to addict's point like they couldn't
have known because like i was the only
one that knew so thank you
you were the prophet yes yes yes yes
correct okay now now to your point cog
you said something really important
today that i want to expand upon is the
fact that more than anything what this
purchase should do to sony
is push them to improve their
deficiencies
whether organically or through smaller
purchases which they it is their right
to do and i would not be begrudge them
if they did that
one thing i didn't talk about touched on
last week because there was so much to
talk about is that
when you when you think about
for somebody like me who's kind of been
in gaming from the very beginning i've
seen it kind of from the pong days right
at every st
every sort of transformative moment
in gaming every sort of
point of inflection in gaming
there is
something that happens that is
absolutely
that sort of shifts the paradigm right
yeah
and
we had it with we had in the very
beginning when atari just collapsed
completely
and died
and
and
right
that's unfair but shout out to
and then when you look at what happened
afterwards
see nobody
people don't remember that when nobody
wanted to hear anything associated with
any kind of video game nothing
no kind of video game nintendo jumps in
with a fat little mustache plumber and
people are like wait a minute and all of
a sudden it starts all over again
nintendo came back and once again
shifted the paradigm completely changed
the game and brought video games back to
prominence then what happens right
you get
the snes you get all those improvements
in that way and then what happens you
get a little bit of hubris from nintendo
right what happens right
they slap somebody off to the side
they're like no you're not you're not
making our cd system oh word
i got you guys
here we go playstation
right a kickstake in the teeth kick
nintendo on the teeth nintendo wants to
keep making cartridges cool now if
anybody here remembers
when they when the 3do came out when the
phillips cdi came out when the
playstation came out there were plenty
of people
naysayers like oh disc based games no
way yup that's not the future no no no
that's not the future yeah cartridges
all the way good i believe this this is
going to be this is going to be the
industry yeah yeah exactly shake up the
industry another inflection point that
was initiated by sony this time right
versus um what was it no it was blue
versus hdd yeah yep exactly so you had
right
so the thing about it is that every
point in time right and then you have
xbox coming in and changing the game
when it came to hard drives in the box
when it came to online infrastructure
right
every time a company comes in to switch
up and change the paradigm that has
become either stagnated or just the the
people that have been winning have
failed to sort of move the industry
forward in a significant way something
happens to shake it up and the reality
of it is that if if we look at game
passes that moment right game passing
what xbox is doing with with the with
their ecosystem right now
is that
it wouldn't be working
if the market didn't want it if the
market didn't want it it would be dead
in the water we would not be talking
about this right so all the people
that were talking about you know and
this goes back to the collins argument
like it's just you being afraid of
changing
the status quo that you've been used to
right since the play since playstation
jumped in and changed the status quo
right god knows how many years ago right
now
he admitted that's why i asked that's
why i used the um
the jordan lebron thing exactly the old
heads because you know what i'm saying
but at the end of the day like when we
see where the industry is going and
stuff like that and it's just like yo
this this is happening you know what i'm
saying kind of thing it's just happening
this is happening so the thing about it
is when you look at these numbers and
people see this growth and it's like oh
no here it goes it's the market saying
hey this is where we want yeah the
market is saying market is dictating it
right so
when it comes to what these other
companies have to do and we had this
discussion last week as well
the fact of the matter is
it there is a very real impending threat
from the amazons from the googles from
the neteases from from the what's your
caller from the embrace well bracer is
monster exactly
from 10 cent
and the fact of the matter is that if
there is anybody with the cash to sort
of make sure that at that the paradigm
shift in gaming stays
for the most part stays to subscription
services and not all this other negative
stuff that we can have coming in and we
can talk about nfts and all that stuff
right
it's microsoft it's microsoft so i'm not
i you know
we we all have to remember history as it
happened and history as it happened is
that playstation came in at a time
and and shook things up yes and made
people change the way they think about
cartridge
service cds not going to work load times
are bad for gaming it's disruptive
disruptive i remember and you know all
the music is nice but nah
polygons and it's like you have to
remember that and and and not be
hypocritical when you look at what
microsoft is doing right now and be like
oh it's bad for gaming it's just that
it's just that early sense of fear
at changing what we know right um so to
see this growth i think is it's amazing
i i'm excited to see where this goes
whether it's a little bit scary or not
that's fine
but
we've been here multiple times before
and we've been fine so i think we'll be
fine yeah it's an inflection point you
know i will say though in the defense of
people on the sides of the argument that
one example of it going wrong
is the xbox one era when you're too
aggressive and your market is not ready
yet you know what i'm saying so the
market wasn't ready yet for the digital
only future even though that's where it
was going
they didn't i think where microsoft
learned
is and phil said it eloquently recently
their model does not depend
solely on game pass being successful
they still want that whole mixed aspect
they still want respect retail they
still got cloud they still got you know
what i'm saying
is is that ass okay is what you're
saying more of um
spiel
and corporate talk
because all right
you know um that's what dominant said
i'm just yeah well exactly i still
obviously believe that uh he has to
watch exactly how he speaks because you
have a relationship with retailers of
course of course
you still produce a box that uh has this
of course and that's the box that is the
hardest to find
you know it's a reason why the digital
box is um
readily easier to find right and i
believe that's with the same with the
playstation 5 as well there's a reason
why the disc version is the hardest one
to get because that one is really the
one that is actually getting to the con
to the to the stores
you'll understand that the retailers
want more of you know they will probably
shun uh the the digital boxes because
that uh reveals their mortality to be
honest with you because at some point in
time
when it all turns digital
the only thing that you will have in
stock is the box and you won't have the
games where they make the revenue off of
they actually make a ton of revenue off
of these games so
i think in his conversation he has to
shield
retailers and to let retailers know that
it's okay the same way sony came out and
had uh these contracts will be honored
type of thing you know um there's a fear
of mortality there you know we've
watched nec go under we've watched sega
go under we've watched these companies
go under don't forget 3do panasonic and
all these other companies people we
don't talk from an aspect of not being
their front line
taking the losses on this hardware you
know we we were the test dummies for
game fly for uh for all live
other stuff that actually failed some of
you guys uh uh purchased um
what was that uh stadia some of you guys
got in on stadia and are sitting on the
sidelines talking about man i was fooled
and i thought this would be it and that
was probably your first taste at a
company folding so when other when you
see
the there's a competition going
and you know and i'm pretty sure
nintendo revenue is end on and higher
right oh same thing with microsoft
you look at this race and you say who
can actually fall out of this race
nintendo has stand the test of time with
everyone right and they're still there
so you put nintendo to the side and you
say and they've done stuff that is
contrary to what the market is doing so
you're not fearful of that then you look
at the other two
so if you look at one success you have
to look at the mortality of the other
one and you fear that i'm telling you
don't fear change change is going to be
inevitable but
what can grow out of this is i can get
your games on my platform
that's your narrative i'm not going
there so let me finish that get back to
you very good guys looking for me to be
messy yes i know you've been able to get
my little yeah
yeah i raised the head when you when you
brought up the argument about um
them not only relying on the success of
game pass because there was a very
interesting uh interview with sarah bond
about a couple of months ago and she was
asked the question where does she see
xbox and the ecosystem in 10 years on
the 30th anniversary
and she actually spoke about that and
she compared game pass to other forms of
entertainment like music books movies
etc and she said uh something
interesting that i didn't know that uh
in the music even though we all use
spotify or whatnot um
these streaming services um the the
music industry still makes a 30 to 40
percent uh off of
regular retail sales and the same
applies apparently to books and
movies um and and tv series etc and so
she expects of course the market
shifting towards subscription services
and digital
purchases but uh she's not seeing a reta
classic retail sales going anywhere and
i find that quite interesting um
and quite interesting aspect because
that's what xbox has been um actually
advertising all along and they want
options they want options yeah because
it's not about making the ecosystem this
way it's about providing a variety
exactly but i do understand what king is
going and i don't even know me and him
class sometimes with that i do
understand what he's going in one sense
in the sense that to me
this is my opinion i i think we're still
in that transitionary phrase to get to
where king wants it to go and i think
there is something that has to be in
place to protect you know those retail
relationships so to speak and you know
you still have a base that for the most
part your competitors are still they're
not as aggressively pushing into that
space like you are right because like
they're kind of pioneering and pushing
they're like we're the netflix of game
and you can download it and you can go
retail you get we give you all these
options yeah and the cloud stuff like
that so it's going to be interesting to
see i'm going to get my balls up quick
so we going way long on the top
but um look this is impressive you know
this is impressive um
you know i'm with attic in a sense as
long as it's growth oh you know i'm fine
you know it's but what the thing that
was interesting to me though was the
halo and the forza situation and you
know the halo of the 20 and i'm like
okay that that's what's up you know but
the forza to me and i want to pose this
right back we get adequate on this i'm
curious because
they did the 18 mil now the conversation
at the time we had and king remembers we
was like yo i don't know if that's a
good move to have them in such close
proximity to that remember we was like
yo maybe forza should be allowed to rock
you let that halo give
i was guilty of this so this is i'm
clearly wrong here because it shows
that the proximity really didn't matter
didn't really affect the concurrent
nature of of people there and i want to
i want to ask you that that's the first
thing and then the second thing i notice
and i want to give forza it's roses is
that
we're seeing that strength in china
with forza specifically it's becoming
the international game and let's be real
halo
half of it is free to play
right so if theory forza could look at
you be like yo this 18 off the rep
you know what i'm saying like y'all had
20 but your 20 is really a lot of free
to play you know i'm saying like it's an
interesting argument and the fact that
we talked i'm glad we got voxenburg on
because we talked about localization
and you see forza like yo this week
china for localization then we realize
how much of a dominant place and market
we have in all these regions we're
adding region specific cars like classic
chinese vehicles and all these other
things that like really cater to the
market you see them doing it in
different markets and you see those
markets internationally appreciating
that so the question i got back there
y'all start with attic is that
is forza
the real king out here in these x-fox
streets
what say addict
addicts in the third dimension oh you
talking about forza yeah who the king
who the king that is
is is our halo got the double
but is it is it really is it is it
foster though
i think i think they're both
i think they're both king
at the end of the day like
forza is a is a racing game competing
with a shooter like i i don't know the
thing is is like we do got to take into
consideration that
just because these
games have a high
amount of people that's that's drove in
there
how many people was actually playing it
like right now right like because
we got to keep that consideration i know
that it's it does decent on steam and
it's usually halo's usually like
the top ten i mean numbers go down all
the time they go up and down up and down
so you know we'll just have to see
i don't like that okay
i don't like that because then it
changes the talk
it changes the talk from peak view to
what's consistent you know like it
changes
on 99
off the rip okay
it's the thought that
you know and it gives credence to the
troll
you know because it gives the troll a
little escape hatch no i'm not even
talking to you you're not talking about
internal in-house you know just yeah
because but it's this is okay
halo's the king okay
numbers reflect that two million ahead
and you had a head start and we still
punched you in the mouth i don't care if
we're in the same house i'm still big
brother okay okay okay i see you all go
again if they had the most okay okay
okay
i i don't care if i gave you a head
start i still want to race god bless
sit down i'm big brother so
we're not going to go with oh who's
concurrently doing this we're not doing
that we're doing pink numbers shut up
sit down
i'm the boss
and you know how until little brother
and son can appreciate this
until a little brother can give me that
lay down stay down
you little brother
choke me out get that and i do
understand that to a point but i do
think it does matter how many people is
actually playing the stuff consistently
like
like look like
especially halo it doesn't matter of 8
million 25 million 40 million people
played it if only 50 000 people playing
it that's the number that matters for a
game like that i'm not saying halo's in
a bad spot it might be going down the
numbers
it's it's been out for a while that's
what these well it came in number two i
mean to to to your to your own metric it
came in number two only behind call of
duty yeah so
no one's saying that it's a failure i
all i'm saying is
we always go off on like you know when
it comes to certain games off if you can
only get one playthrough if you know it
has a lot of replay value you know god
of war uncharted 4 so 34 what however
million 20 million
but at the end of the day that's cool
and it shows how much those games sold
but those are single-player games they
can get away with that a little bit more
but when you play as a games as a
service it's a different metrics because
it matters how many people's constantly
playing
because look look prime example sea of
thieves the arena was not doing that
right so they had to shut down that mode
and see thieves right and if if
the millions and millions
of millions if they were playing that
particular game mode and populating that
game mode it would still be there but
when it's not being populated and it's
just wasting server room they gotta cut
it gotta cut it yeah
and you know what you're 100 right and
i'm in on it i'm just being a troll and
talking from a troll aspect of it you
know um
but uh and i know what you're saying to
even compete with something that's all i
was saying yeah
you know a little brother did give a
good go at it you know he did put up
numbers that
that made people a little reflective
like you know can halo even compete with
what's in house
and all i'm saying is big brother is
always big brother no doubt solved in
boxing quickly
yeah it does not change who's the king
of xbox games no but but i think it is
an interesting conversation because of
the things you guys have mentioned
because with halo being free to play
right
the way that game is engaged with is
different now than core halo right um
and you know i don't believe all the
stuff that people online you know oh
it's dying it's whatever it's it's it's
it's hills and valleys right and i i do
think they have to
improve their cadence their cadence of
sort of like of of release
let first off let me correct people in
the people saying attic 50 000 that was
just random numbers thrown out i don't
know i don't play on the cheating pc
crowd so i don't know what they're doing
over there i gotta get it if it's
citizens and addicts not in color so
yeah that was boring
shout out to sid
that was boss
so that metric again if
they have to be careful and i've said
this before if they don't make sure they
stick to the cadence that people who
play free to play games expect yes the
numbers are going to drop and and it's
going to be now the thing with forza
horizon is different is that this game
is a game that's a little more
transcendent because it it's a casual
game it is a game that anybody can get
in and play it's like a national or is
the motor sport proper it's not getting
these numb back at all it's just not
going to happen i'm with you because
it was the key
so horizon is in a special position
where the game is finally getting the
love that it deserves it is doing these
things internationally to appeal to
those different types of of gamers
and in the long term i maybe a little
brother could step up right
don't let that drop that tokyo halo nick
see oh
but
the co-op you're talking about matters
to old school halo head
doesn't necessarily matter
how does the forge ma
we're going to get into we go
we got a topic for certain definitions
the thing is though when it comes to
certain of these games like i don't
think every game microsoft's going to do
like people have this narrative that
microsoft's going to
navigate and try to turn every game they
have in the games and service and that's
just not true like
they do have games that they want to be
as games of service and i do think
specifically
internally microsoft if it is possible
to turn a game into a game as a service
which halo could have always been at
games as a service but it was never
turned into one so i don't problem i
don't see i don't see an issue with them
turning something like halo into the
game's deserves now if they turn
something like fable and perfect dart
then what i knew he was going to go see
that
if it makes sense turning into a games
as a service i don't mind gears totally
makes sense that that's his games of
service forza has the season stuff so
that makes sense during that is the
games game's disservice halo it
should probably always been in games as
a service that would make sense
actual question what if they take the
multiplayer aspect of fable because you
know we need a multiplayer component
fable legends two baby
it's being made by the same people that
made the seasons before there we go
that's my dude there's something they
can definitely do something there but
the thing is is like
these games as a service stuff is it
designed
to give you all everything at once
right what it is is like halos
vanilla story could have been better but
i thought it was appropriate and it did
what i needed it done right uh forza it
seemed like what people are talking
about is like oh next year you know when
you have the next four as a drop and you
have all these games drop the star
filled alongside these games you're
going to have the next expansion of halo
being marketed with these
facts when they do
probably
before the three months before that halo
expansion started marketing you know
they're going to start marketing the
next forza experience that's going on
there with the winner or whatever it is
then they'll probably the next year
they'll drop the lego stuff
this service is designed that's right
hot wheels and i want i want fable to be
right up in that mix
i don't mind if they turn it into a
games or service as long as it makes
sense and it works well like white
slides you turn fable into yeah
uh like wasteland three
that game isn't at games as a service
but they're like yo instead of doing a
games as a service model let's just drop
dlc and have people buy it on gamepad
yeah no doubt no doubt boxing burns just
real quickly y'all should know hey uh
forza vs halo in your eye who's who's
king who's not who's coming who's that
what's
it's a
tough question to answer the thing is
with forza horizon um and the success of
watson horizon with 80 million players
they have achieved something that is
really special because now a racing game
is in on that level where we talk about
is that king
i mean that our conversation alone just
tells you that this is a massive success
and that they have
put a racing game into a position
the casual gaming market picks it up um
and that is something unique because
like you mentioned thoughts and
motorsport probably won't do that yeah
yeah you see but it wasn't i mean you
know i'm kind of going down the first
motorsport i did forget that this one
solved correctly for wrong and boxing
cracking one there it's just going to be
like name forza and
it's a reboot it's not a number right so
they got it they're going to infinite
sports yeah yeah and it's going to be a
service yeah it's going to be a service
okay oh
that deserves to be confirmed
it pretty much kind of
indicated that that was that's what it's
going to be like it's going to be this i
know it's a rumor that there's a rumor
yeah it's a movement
it's a rumor it's a ruler it deserves to
be because
we consume racing
we we consume racing in seasons right so
um why not do that why not have that
approach
would make sense yeah
yeah anyway i would love it good topic
and then we went extra long but a lot
little terrible i didn't expect that
yeah this
[Music]
to our friends because listen when we
get to 15 000 subscribers we will give
away that console so if you want that
oled uh old led
nintendo switch we got you if you want
that playstation underpowered five we
got you and if you want the
power we got that xbox series and if you
want little man to make your little man
a little girl happy hey we got that so
uh just uh share it out get everybody
like actually to be honest with you
whatever you gave one just add me
and um we will have mad fun
no doubt and um i got to do the youtube
thing um sorry so it's only 400 likes in
here click the like button click the
like button if it saves puppies and
children please
hit the like button thank you i can
actually ask the question yes what if we
win should we give away an oculus vr we
might be able to discuss something about
that yeah man console of choice
yeah money
absolutely absolutely who the hell else
is doing that that's how does this work
yo you might get a chance to game with
us or actually go see a concert with us
or watch a basketball game
and you know what else man i'm feeling
very generous i'll even give you my time
machine so you know
thank you for your service and
contribution
oh what you got what you got you ready
saw some yeah ready to rock
we have joe dunmore five dollars if you
chat there will be no sony playstation 6
but there will be a microsoft
playstation 6. oh wow
wow
i like you
[Laughter]
messy
then we have the everborn saga two
dollar super chat don't worry if phil
writes rhymes he writes checks
that's a bar
that's a ball right there we know what
that's from that's that whole
there you go then we got donald taco
five dollar super chat but pokemon
legends arceus just came out and that's
way more important than microsoft buying
activism blizzard king let's get an
extra three hours on that topic
no no pokemon addict nothing
well you know right now he can't talk
about pokemon but listen
we know for a fact that nintendo ain't
going nowhere as much as we try to get
them up out of here they put our
cardboard and you brought it so god
bless you yeah
then we got parasite 82 green uh four
pound and 49 pence super chat when
microsoft dropped the activism blizzard
news reminded me of when nas came at day
with ether that was my first damn moment
of 2022.
ethereum
and we got cmad five dollar super chat
what percentage of the 480 million
active activision blizz users do you all
feel xbox can flip to game pass all 480
of them
why you think they got purchased one
percent of 4.8 is 4.8 million 3 is 14.4
million five percent is 24 million 10 is
48 million where is game pass at the end
of 2023 that that that kind of makes
sense but if you do something in your
provisional clause
to convert those uh
those uh accounts over to game pass
instantly game pass becomes a complete
joke or not yeah and i want to point out
too that
game passes gra has grown this much off
of like very little first party support
it's been a lot of indies a lot of
third-party support like
i think
right now they're expecting
their biggest growth is when you start
seeing the fables drop the vows drop the
perfect dard's drop like when they had
these games coming out every three
months that their point is to not only
keep people to to get people to come on
they're also trying to keep people on
the surface too yep
make you can't live without it like
netflix
then we have necromancer zale five
dollars of a chat sony's next big
announcement will be getting purchased
by microsoft wow uh i i just wanted to
have a third to party developer
i know i think it is possible someone
like disney buys my uh sony though no
netflix
that's crazy
then we have cheney five dollar super
chat retailers putting up signs on
playstation displays warning about no
cod chip
bending the knee wow really i saw
something i don't know who if that yeah
i don't know if it was a fan that did
that or actually telling that to stick
up like you're working so far
be careful
oh they didn't have that conversation
inside stores i'm not gonna say who
cause i don't wanna try to get these
dudes fired but that's out of control
yeah i don't i don't see a realistic
reason why retailers would even tell
consumers
anything yeah exactly exactly
by the time the actual next by the time
this happens there might be two cars
that came out so yeah
yeah so that doesn't make a lot of sense
that would be stupid um then we have
voidlock spartan remember for two months
thank you sir we got a little man up
front here man hit the like button game
passes the netflix of netflix of gaming
playstation afterthought is the 2b tv of
gaming wow
we know it won't be day one yeah
probably not i hope so i hope that i
hope jim is watching and understands to
to shake the world
that will happen mm-hmm
he needs to do that but we'll see
splendiferous five dollar super chat i
love boxing burger but i gotta give him
a hard time no love lost skyrim is one
of my favorites of all time but sega is
personal you want to eat you said he
says he wants to eat the cake but don't
want to come in
wow
jesus man
the bad game is thinking love what do
you want like i want him to do
it's it's just like this
he went out to the black market and
copped his jaw
with a hoodie on nobody threatened the
rest come on nobody in the region reppin
he went out to go get it like come on
and we have lucious augustus member for
six months
lord braun shout out to you sir every
time there's a change in the industry
there's always trade-offs disruption
typically helps the consumer i'm with it
there you go change is inevitable
and we have heart chinese five dollar
super chat solve facts
industries change over time do you see
amazon google or apple disrupting gaming
what about 10 cent will one of them
change things
we don't have any idea what tencent is
planning to do but intensive tencent is
making more money than anybody in gaming
which is
scary and then apple google and amazon
uh
you know what it is i think the draw
to
not having to have an actual
the draw to everything being online and
in the cloud was too much for amazon and
google to resist i think
because when you think about it after
the infrastructure and the what you
don't have the same overhead you have
making games in the traditional way you
just don't
and i think to them they're like oh my
god we can make all this money if we
have this infrastructure that we have in
place already and it's not quite what
they expected it to be so shout out to
microsoft keep doing what you're doing i
think netflix i think out of all of that
you you fail to put netflix in that
space and i'm always telling you guys be
cognizant of the fact that sony has a
hell of a category in a library
that if netflix was ever to purchase
sony out in his entirety that means sony
movies and and those ips that they do
have to be made because they're always
looking for new content remember could
you imagine god of war as a netflix
series they're already doing the last of
us and they put eight eight seasons
unprecedented stuff i mean look at the
tea leaves if they was to either
purchase a partnership with them cash
influx with sony they will already have
a console that's in the market and they
can do things
uh with that iep with those ips
that microsoft cannot do
not for sure for sure
we got something bad yeah we got uh let
me see
lucasfox five dollars super chat saab is
100 right the market dick takes it dick
takes success and will always choose the
intersection of convenience and value
very good very well put
streaming games is the future yeah we
don't know how close that future
actually is
but yeah it it probably is
then we have jd gamer remember for 23
months thank you
jd if sony had to make a purchase in
order to get a good multiplayer game
under their umbrella i would predict
ubisoft or better yet cry tech cry tech
looks good
absolutely absolutely i've always said
that microsoft should swoop up
developer uh i'm with you brother give
me my rise and that engine is fire
there's something going on with them
yeah i don't i don't understand it yeah
it's it's really weird because crytek
was really under financial problems a
couple of years ago
the german government jumped in and they
had to support them for a while
otherwise they would have shut down and
it's um yeah
yeah they haven't released a proper game
outside of hand yeah
for what now 10 years or so yeah good
point good point guys up i think hun
actually helped save them too because
that was a successful game on pc yeah
that's what's up
then we have harget chaney five dollars
we chat wait
games are required to continue to be
played
damn sony is a massive failure who plays
those games more than once they're one
and done
rest in peace playstation wow
come on now
then we have jd gamer once again 10
super chat sony has a compounded problem
with losing call of duty they lose their
portion of the game purchase price micro
transactions and potentially millions of
ps plus subscriptions that's going to
hurt sony's bottom line
yeah it will if that happens wholesale
that's for sure
then we have don otaku 10 super chat
yeah that forza horizon that forza
horizon 5 with 18 million players is
cute but mario kart 8 pushing 50 million
and the game really goes on sale respect
the real racing go okay that is true
that is 100 true now what i wonder is
do they do they do they count bundle
sales with that mario kart because
they've been selling that mario kart
bundle i think for like five christmases
that's why that's why when people bring
up like
like
certain like a certain big franchise
this goes for every xbox playstation
like oh uncharted so 25 halos five so
this is like then they've also bundled
these games a hundred times like yeah
you gotta respect it it's a hustle and
no one's taking away that mario kart
it's not just a beast mario kart is
something that everybody can get into
your three-year-old kid cannot pick up
forza at five and be like yo let's go
beat cog like
that's not gonna happen damn incognito
running me over
what else we got what else we got we got
lord metroid two dollar super chat king
shoveling skyward sword off the trash
earlier geez
you know you keep coming for skyward
sword but those numbers look really good
over there in the nintendo so put on
your eye patches and look them up
what else we got there we have jb gaber
once again ten dollar super chat we have
to stop that fake narrative that racing
games are or have ever been niche
started by envious playstation fans yan
turismo was playstation's highest
selling franchise and stayed that way
for decades racing is casual
uh yeah
mostly yes i don't know
thing about gran turismo is
it was the market was different then i'm
excited to see what gran turismo 7 does
um be in a world where it's still kind
of close obviously it's going to be on
ps4 ps5
i would have loved to have them day and
day or at least close to day and date on
the pc because again like you say that
game needs as big of an audience as
possible especially considering the fact
that it is a sim racer it isn't what
forza horizon is so i i want to see what
it means
what it does i think i'm buying it um
definitely
but
i always thought racing wasn't niche i
always thought it was casual because of
uh need for speed road rash those games
like that uh you know pole position
outrun uh games of that don't don't
the way that gran turismo changed the
game is they made it more cinematic uh
that made the games look
photo realistic that was the first time
i see photo religion in car games yeah
so
but the reason why the playstation uh
fan is will call it niche is because
gran turismo comes out in such a long
distance cadence
where you had uh forza coming out at a
higher cadence
and they change and diversified with
horizon so i can understand why one
aspect would say that because they don't
get a chance to have that same cadence
one platform no doubt yeah
we got to get moving one more that we
have a stitch with the remember for 27
months thank you sir microsoft keeping
the boot on sony's neck but don't finish
them off yet i want to enjoy the misery
a little while longer hashtag remember
sega
it's so well known for his objectivity
so
fortnite let them crawl around while i
hunt their friend
anyway so we all caught up and then um
yeah i just want to read the uh the
merch shout out to smitty smith got that
10k salute to all the classic t says who
to the lord's boxing burger and chat
hashtag the book of ex
salute that's the embrace anybody's
listening right now
the word is going out tonight that 10k
merch is coming down
all right i'm telling you now like for
for all the people that was riding with
us to get to 10k subscribers thank you
so much
and and that was for y'all and we went
out personally and i was agonizing over
it trying to get it just right it fire
that that i want that shirt to go down
in history yeah i really do because you
guys made history and i thank you so
much but it's going down tonight
you gonna make the call i'll tell you i
better get it yeah i got
it just letting y'all know you already
know soft you are up what the hell is
going on with star wars and respawn
yeah man so uh it was announced earlier
well earlier this week respawn and ea
announced uh what has basically turned
out to be their final three star wars
games um that i think i don't know if
they fall under their ex exclusivity
agreement but i it's the last three
they're gonna make
and ea has made the correct choice in
allowing respawn to helm all of them in
some way shape or form
so may i correct you here let's go
really not that
it's the last three games it's the last
three games that they publish under the
exclusivity deal well that's the thing i
wasn't sure if that if that said that
they said that if they are not done with
making star wars games they will
continue to make them so where did they
say that because they said someplace
else i want to know because they they
said someplace else that they were
the investor call that they had where
they actually announced the entire thing
okay okay because somewhere else i read
that they said they'd rather focus on
their own ip after these three games and
not continue making star wars games i
think i've read that too and i think
that they were referring uh to respawn
specifically okay not easy not
okay okay so if that is the case then we
we may see battlefront continue with
dice and stuff like that so okay we'll
probably see titanfall 3 then
hopefully we'll talk about it fully
we'll talk about that but yeah
so uh yeah so the three games that are
they they basically haven't fully they
haven't fully announced exactly what
they are but they've given us
indications of what type of games they
are so the first one coming out of um
respawn is a sequel to jedi fallen order
that's what everybody is expecting that
to be they said it's the next game in
the jet in the jedi series but we expect
it to be the direct sequel to jedi
fallen order which did fantastically for
them uh i really enjoyed that game did
everyone here play that i don't know if
king played it yeah yeah that was good i
i got my my words for the game i mean i
gotta go back now that it's 60 frames
per second because i had issues with uh
a lot of this yeah there was there was
some stuff early on yeah
the second game which is very
interesting is an fps game
um that obviously is going to be
different especially now hearing what
boxing burger said that that that a
battlefront contin will most more than
likely continue with dice um
it could be very interesting to see you
know i'm an old school star wars fan to
see like a dark forces type gang come
back or
a republic commandos type game come back
would be exciting for me in the star
wars universe
and then uh for addict and cog
we have
a toe all right boxing burger as well
strategy a turn-based strategy game
coming from a team
that is made up of a a lot of
extra-access guys that make uh make your
beloved x-com
so guys tell me what you think about
this it's exciting for me because i
think
like we've said in the past respawn
doesn't miss they haven't missed
they haven't missed they've never missed
um
so it's very exciting to see that they
are going to be at the helm of these
these games that are coming at the tail
end of this exclusivity agreement i
think it's a smart thing to do i think
it's good to give people a break from
battlefront even though battlefront at
the end of its life cycle is a
considerably better game than what it
was when it first came out i think sir
you know respawn respawn had the perfect
antidote for that which is coming in
with a hot jedi game you give people
lightsabers and it's good
um i think really just uplifted the
whole the whole spirit around that
exclusivity agreement and whatever i
think just made the bad taste in
people's mouths be better um so
what do you guys think about these games
and what do you think they are going to
be lord boxenberger our esteemed guest
what you think sir
oh um
i start with jedi fallen order uh i'm
super excited uh the rumor says this
comes out this fall um and respawn said
that they started to work on the sequel
even before the first one came out so
okay
that game has been a while in
development and um i would i i'm i'm
really excited to see what they do with
the second one i love the first one it
was my game of the year that year um
was it perfect no obviously not but um
it was an amazing game and it
didn't um
didn't do the the typical ea thing you
know it's it wasn't a frostbite engine
game it was an unreal engine game it was
a single-player game no
microtransactions no dlc it was so
atypical for ea so really looking
forward to see what they do with the
sequel there um
then we have the first person shooter of
course everyone thinks first battlefront
um but that's why i investigated a
little bit and uh i found that they said
in the during the investor call um
apparently they that they are continuing
to make star wars games just not under
the exclusive uh exclusivity
uh license deal so
i don't know what what it's going to be
given that um
how great titanfall was and how we
create the campaign for titanfall 2
yeah
i really want to see
what they do with the first person
shooter um in the star wars realm good
point i don't think that we will see
that game
soon though i think that game is a
couple of years out um so
yeah
and um the third one is is the one that
is really interesting
i didn't know that it's term based i
just read strategy but yeah yeah i'll
take it uh i'll take it um love me some
uh turn-based strategy games yeah
[Laughter]
the thing here i know how much you love
your stack this is
[Music]
um
see the thing is i i didn't know who bit
reactor was so i looked it up and would
that research tell you
yeah and that is the studio in indie
studio that is founded by the creators
of civilization and i can save yes
how can you not be excited then for
strategy gaming and star wars and we
know a lot of other star wars games are
coming we know about the ubisoft uh game
it's going to be a ubisoft open world
game i love the ubisoft games but yeah
we know what we will get there um we
know about the quantity dream game which
is going to be an action adventure game
we know about the kotor remake and
we all know about these games there's
really when has there ever been a proper
star wars strategy game yeah i can't
remember never i really can't so um yeah
i i definitely want to star wars chess
maybe
original battlefronts there was a
conquest mode that had a little bit of
strategy to it oh okay
yeah no doubt yeah yeah no good good
good uh good points blowing boxing lord
attic man three
respawn star wars games we at
i think they're uh a fantastic student
kind of worried about working on three
games
did they say if it's at the same time or
not
i mean
i would i would think so they're going
to talk about that ladies work on all
three of them so
because you know
when you when you shoot one bullet at a
time you do good but when you start
shooting three you know
you know maybe one maybe one two ain't
gonna hit which i i got a lot of faith
in them so we'll have to see exactly
what happens um you know we'll see okay
um king where you at
um
i have different thoughts on the jedi
fallen order
sequel spicy um because watching uh the
book of boba fett i got a chance to see
that uh his droid unit that was from um
from jedi fallen order and
i want to know how the jedi dies
right uh that he gets separated from his
droid unit or what happens that he gets
separated from his droid unit so i think
part two fleshes that out i will hope
that part two is a a current gen uh and
when i'm saying current gentleman's
series uh console playstation five
console uh pc
um 3080 type of stuff um i want current
gen i think the last gen has been
holding us back as far as uh what we're
able to achieve
um
so
yes i want 60 frames 120 frames i want
high fidelity i want hopefully uh 904s
bite unroll engine fine
and that's that's what i like vince for
you know he does what's in the best
interest of the consumer as far as uh
not necessarily going with what's best
interest of the company and their bottom
line if you need to purchase a
engine
uh to achieve the highest uh fidelity
then do so or to achieve what the studio
needs done yeah
i think great games uh dictate sales
right so we all knew that jedi fall in
order the first one
a admit a little bit of flaws was still
a great game yeah
the first person shooter i want to know
who's it going to be is it going to be
cad bane would it be uh the mandalorian
would it be
another bounty hunter would it be some
obscure uh
character because you know jedi fallen
order gave us a character that we
weren't familiar with and made him a
prominent role inside the jedi universe
so uh star wars has a diverse uh cast i
mean you could have literally um
a storm trooper that decided to defect
like in the movies
and he is uh
the shooter like uh so
the story where that would that story go
what engine would they use i mean
when it comes to ea i'm more concerned
about the engine because
i feel when they force an engine on you
that that that gives us uh unreal
expectations with things and how the
hell yeah yeah
um
right the thing is um
frostbite is in everything yeah the
sports games like fifa man
we have first-person shooters we have
we have everything running in it and
that's not really always a good thing um
because um engines need to be
specialized for certain things and um
i think i know that is what makes unreal
so special in the marketplace that it is
probably the most universal engine out
there versatile yeah yeah yeah and
that's what's being flexible i'm i'm i'm
right there we're talking i'm with him
too i'll give it back to you that's
where with king's point overall point is
you know when the boardroom you try to
cut corners and save money with a
proprietary engine but the proprietary
engine doesn't necessarily facilitate
the needs of the actual game and what
the development is
back when you can all right so and then
when we get to the uh real-time strategy
game
my mind explodes with wonders where
do i get a chance to pick my uh my um
uh
champions in in this game um
is it a bounty hunters game
i'm heavily into that is is it a sith
game is it a jedi game
or do you have to do you uh get a chance
to pick which side did you on are you on
the light or are you the dark or or or
are you uh the the order or
you know it's it's just so many
different aspects that it can take and
and taking these aspects from the world
because i'm steeped in star wars lore
not to this to the point that i'm a
fanatic because i also love star trek so
you can't serve two masters but
right i would love a star trek game um
but at the same time
could you imagine pitting different
bounty hunters together in a squad
that's going in and and then it's taking
out the imperial order uh oh or let's
say that it it starts on the on the
world of mandalore where you're actually
in the mandalore wars and you're
fighting over the black saber to control
that it's different things that you can
do and in these strategy aspects you can
have
or or
of the bad batch you can actually have a
game about the bad batch and if no if
you don't understand who the bad batch
is all right so in the clone wars
clones are made from one uh
specific character and they're all over
the place and sometimes they will have a
bad a clone that comes up and they call
them the bad batch and these guys uh
have a ragtag group they did things
unorthodox not and they didn't think
like regular clones but they all
specialize in different areas so you
could take that whole bad batch that is
specialized one is a grunt one is a
sniper one is a uh um
a technician the other one is an
all-around uh type of character and you
can take these characters and head out
on different missions with specialized
characters and i think that aspect of it
not knowing is the best part to me yeah
because then you get to wonder and you
get to to to to believe so i think the
force by engine works well here
and it's not really necessarily uh that
is uh important uh what engine is being
used here
but
i'm more excited for this part
because this is something that i've been
asking for star wars to tackle for a
long time in my head and now it's coming
to the realization and i'm glad that
they didn't go with first person first
person first person yeah they split it
up with single-player storyline driven
game first-person shooter and a
real-time strategy and everyone should
champion this whole aspect of it because
they didn't just say oh we're gonna
monetize this and make money from this
they went all across the spectrum yeah
i'm sorry
do you think they try to fill the void
left by sort of um by battlefront and do
it more like a multiplayer thing on the
first person shooter side or do you
think it's going to be like a story
driven
first person i think they looked at um
and i think everyone is going to look at
how microsoft took their most important
ip in halo and split it
you know so they took
what everybody was fearful of as far as
um
are they going to uh
just put out the multiplayer and just
skimp on the single player and
knowing ea
knowing that if they can do this in the
same cadence they can make it live on
and keep dropping out episodes or
dropping out different characters that
can
facilitate a different play mechanics
they can do that so i think
you have that first person
single experience
to satiate the crowd and i think you
have that multiplayer aspect to that
same game that can fulfill the the the
battlefront people in that whole aspect
as well and if they use that two-prong
approach to it they won't get as
criticized as often as they are no no
that's a good point i'll jump in um
you know this is great news but cog is
still sad
[ __ ] is still sad because i think like
voxenberger said that means my titan 4-3
is all the way in the bushes
all the way in the bushes they can sit
there and say yeah we we haven't given
up but your docket got very busy what
i'm saying because at the end of the day
you know battlefield vince got a sign to
save that right battlefield now is in
the bushes again watching it again but
surprisingly and they sent him over
there to go save that so he he's got his
teams and stuff like that now we hear
about this which is fantastic don't get
me wrong for star wars this is fantastic
i'm with soft respawn has not made a
wack game yet in my opinion everything
they hit you can say it's good or you
know you can't you know if you don't
like winning games you can say it's good
but you can't say like apex or whatever
and these other games are bad games i
don't even like battle royale like that
and i know apex is a good game you know
what i'm saying so at the end of the day
look this is gonna be vince got his work
cut out they are busy the docket is busy
but um this the future for star wars
bright it just shows me like how much
trust ea has in vince how vince is just
elevated to have this much control this
much say so you know and then the rumors
we're hearing um shout out to tom
henderson
they were saying that um
jedi fell in order they expected maybe
something it was already in development
right so they're expecting a potential
reveal maybe at star wars day in may you
know i mean so we could see that
and you know i want to shout out our boy
patrick wren you know what i'm saying
formerly of 343 now over there at
respawn working on star wars games i
don't know which one he's on but hey you
know what i'm saying giving them that
extra experience of what he did is going
to be great fps star wars is interesting
i want to know what they focus on if
there's going to be
a multiplayer kind of battlefront thing
and or if they're going to do a full
length story kind of like what king is
talking about but like like uh boxing
burger addicts said like bro when i
heard about a strategy game you know i'm
i've lost it because it's like bit
reactive feraxis to me is the current
goat
with x-com when it comes to
how to do a turn-based strategy game how
to include a story then like boxing
burger said like you know they have
the civilization back or they have like
this could be rts or whatever but it
what we got to know is that is going to
be a quality game how do they tackle it
which part of the star wars universe
they're gonna they're gonna put in there
i'm very sign me up i'm i'm all
the way in on that one and i and jenna
fallon it was it was really really good
it it it did well i think benji sales
put out some information about yeah
eight million
yeah eight million in three months 10
million in five months reached 20
million players in less than two years
the sequel being officially confirmed
today is a very big deal be absolutely
huge and um yeah we like the combat we
like some souls aspects of it the
cinematic nature the third person just
one you know like king said i'm with him
i want my frames i want the fidelity i
would like connection only if possible
really push that life yeah unreal five
oh if they if it's ready i mean i don't
know if they were in transition but if
it's ready man the potential of that so
yeah they look the respawners out here
they're doing well i'm curious to see
they do got a lot on their docket but if
anybody that could do it it's vince i
got trust in vince so that's what i got
super chat's getting the final topics of
yeah okay sliding in on the final topic
and i would like for you guys to hit
that like button because it helps the
algorithm and it stops little puppies
from happy
save the puppies hit the like button
recently read something interesting that
a lot of people don't want to hit the
like button on youtube because they
think because most people use their real
ni
real life name account yeah from google
and they don't want to hit the like
button because they think everyone can
see it like another social media it's
like twitter
like
yeah
it's anonymous
god forbid they they want to tell people
they support this this horrible channel
i won't screenshot all you playstation
dudes that that ripped me and say that
like that like regular thing that like
ratio is up to like eighty ninety
percent we did good today
listen maybe they like the fiscal stuff
that i reported see and the fact that
you can't you know you put dislike but
we can't know who really disliked it
yeah i did a good job for the children
and the puppies no doubt what a children
stop the puppy beating
the puppy
i'm done
you ready
yet another objective take playstation
fans wanted forza to be nice so they
didn't have to admit forza's total
domination of gran turismo over the past
10 years
also i need microsoft to bring in a sobo
avalanche io crystal dynamics and
crystal daddy with the whole world gotta
love jd
industry salute my dude here we go brett
baker five dollars do you think
microsoft will continue to make license
titles of games such as indiana jones
once it releases not on a big scale but
maybe one every two to three years i
think if it's successful
then you have a you have a franchise on
your hands i think i think whoever's
funneling the bag dictates that because
you can get a licensed deal with the
ability to market on whatever platform
it is like they did with disney i think
so yes
yeah for sure then we have king webb one
dollar super chat thank you sir
appreciate it like that yeah
then we have jd gamer two dollar super
chat yes bundles are counted in those
numbers so yeah the mario kart numbers
are a bit inflated with mario kart mario
kart's still to go let me ask you a
question is it inflated when you go out
to get a bundle just because that's your
favorite game
yeah but hardware inflated where you
purchase it to get the free game because
you took it out and you gave it to your
your cousin for his christmas gift but
now
now see this is where they're smart
don't count they don't count digital
sales right but to my knowledge i think
it's a digital version of the game
[Music]
i think i'm not sure don't quote me on
that but i think it's a digital version
of the game in the bundle but they don't
count the doodle sales in mpd though
that's how you get around the door
that's dope
maybe
um
brett baker five dollar super chat
microsoft should have bethesda make a
fallout style star wars mandalorian
first person rpg oh my god
maybe a game as a service no you messed
it up when you got there
like that
you got that i said it i've said it on
another podcast i think the ubisoft game
will be settled in that mandalorian
yeah okay this is gonna be nice yeah and
it's using snowdrop right they're using
the snow drive engine yeah yeah you had
a snow dropper would y'all be looking
nice
then we have thx 1138 10 super chat
disney should bring back star wars 1313
that was cancelled yes did you guys see
that new footage that was yeah man that
was ahead of his time hey boba fett up
there and he was oh my god because this
is what happened 1313 was a thing unto
itself and then they went back to disney
and disney was like great
but we need a recognizable character
change it to boba fett oh
since boba fett is doing so well
you never know
that'd be something that comes back in
some way shape or form that'd be great i
remember i like bounty hunting remember
the star wars bombing yeah of course
yeah that feels good let's get it the
main character was boba fett searching
and claiming bounty around the galaxy
unreal engine five current gen consoles
that would be amazing yes sir
i'm definitely with you necromancer
zelle two dollars super chat i'm worried
about the dead space remake
i don't know man what i saw
early on really yeah yeah
why the worry i guess what it is just
the the studio that's doing it
he's i don't know if their reputation is
the highest and he's concerned about
the
how certain things age might be
translated and take away the spirit of
certain things and if they make a
character talk or something like matty's
very hardcore with dead space and he's
just he's concerned he's so concerned
that he's like you'll play the original
so that you get the essence of what it's
about to be just in case they go off and
let go if they give if they give isaac a
voice that's what he said that's what he
said that's what maddie said
yeah all right so we have brett
binghamton super chat microsoft needs to
buy gsc game world 2.
jesus jesus
let's add that to the list then we have
king web they need to do a two dollar
super chat they need to do a vader game
from the villain side like a straight up
vader game and i'm gonna tell you
something right now king webb take
yourself over to oculus
oh
shout out to cog for opening my eyes
dude the first time you look around and
you are on that starship yeah
you're going to pass out i had to take
it off because i had a tear in my eye
because
this is amazing vader immortal on the
quest is fire yes fire yeah for sure we
got donald taco five dollar super chat
mario kart 8 deluxe still charts on
mpd's every couple of months and is
usually in the top 30 on the e-shop
you're not letting this go
bundles ain't inflating months like i
said it's still to go it's still to go
um i the rumor is that we're gonna get
some sort of announcement on the next
mario kart so i heard that we're going
to be using um the skyward sword birds
we good that's it we're caught up with
it up all right let's get this one uh
it's addict's topic i don't know if i
want me to set it up or got it you could
set it up yeah man this is quick i mean
room room avail y'all a lot of stuff
going on hit that button um yeah we're
here with rumors gears of war collection
potentially you know what i'm saying or
at least one particular um other
franchise which was rumored to be the
gears of fable and then i want to shout
out i believe it was um special nick
from the xbox era shout out to um tom
warren who actually gave more creators
to it said the gears are turning on said
rumor so it's leading credence that it
may be against war collection coming up
and then certain affinity has been in
the news you know and this is they've
been leaked to two potential projects
one is um
monster hunter a co-op monster hunter
game kind of co-published
with uh xbox uh gabe publishing excuse
me and um the second one yeah excuse me
i want to um shout out my man out of
sloth i'll just read his tweet because
he actually wrote like a summary of it
that basically the rumor is xbox game
studios certain video are making a
monster hunter style game it's according
to jeff grubby grub lord jeff grub
salute to him and um so again that is
one of the rumors there and the second
part is halo infinite and this new
rumored mode so salute to law chance
gordon salute to random outdoor xbox 2
podcast the homies so yeah certain
affinities thinking about all bundling
uh building a new game mode for halo
infinite project tatanka
yeah you know according to him they're
supposed to be working on um on that and
it's supposed to be co-developed by
microsoft's flagship shooter halo
infinite and it's supposed to again some
all-new mode so there's a lot of rumors
on what this all new mode could
potentially be
and i want to read jess had a quote that
was pretty much interested he said it
may point one may can also speculate
that um it may point to a battle
royal-like mode which has been a big
question which about where halo infinite
might go 343 industries seems to have
ruled out battle royale for them
in the past though it's hard to say what
it but they basically saying that a
coroner experience is something that
they want to go toward the casual that
they won't see the traditional person
that wouldn't be into a halo game going
so attic
gears of war potential roman collection
monster hunted co-op
halo infinite friendly new mode where
you at with all three
i don't want it to be gears i want it to
be fable
because because i i just personally feel
like
like gears got gears for gears 5 gears
remake he's like come on throw some
fable fans something like they wasn't
like not to mention they they're still
getting gear six
so it's just like come on man like i get
it probably if you're doing like a
master chief collection yeah cause
people were like comparing it to a
master chief collection yeah gears would
make the most sense
but i feel like at that point just do
like what uh
just do what
um
super smash brothers did where it's like
when the game when gear six comes out
just have all the multiplayer maps in
the game like
it's just like i just don't i don't get
it like and i get it people really love
the gears thing and that's cool i i like
the gear story i'm not really the
biggest fan of the multiplayer but it's
just like man like we we just had a
gears like three years ago like busters
too
yeah hive busters like yeah
and this is the same company that let's
say the the this fable reboot or four
doesn't sell the greatest or you know it
doesn't get a lot of attention and
they'll be like whoa you know um i guess
that's just how it is well you know you
put all the money in gears like if you
want to put some kind of remake of like
fable one to get people anticipated to
show them the fable brand because
there's probably two generations worth
of people that i even played fable
okay
we ain't had a fable since like 2013.
because we need to also consider um
that uh all the gears games run with fps
boost
with outer hdr etc so is it really
required and does xbox need gears hype
right now because gear 6 is out yeah we
won't get
that before 24 even 25 probably so
um having a fable reboot come out
probably next year
and um given that fable 3 was 2010
that's 12 years old already yeah it's a
long time
and those games um
at least the first one really didn't age
that well so it could could definitely
benefit from that
uh collection treatment and i would i
would love that and female was uh no i
feel like i feel your favorite community
i've been waiting for a long time
yeah all i'm saying is like if they want
this new fable game because they're
they're putting a lot of money behind
it's like yeah it's like like literally
my brother's generation didn't play it
the generation below his didn't play it
so it's like
like we've had what gear's ultimate
gears four gears five with the amount of
time it's that fable has been missing
we've had four gears games including
gears tactics never have enough
i love gears i love gears but um yeah
it's true we get gears um
the red-headed stepchild and the
situation they ain't getting though
[Laughter]
i hear
um so we we got that part how did you
feel about certain affinities
um other project you know yeah
that was that was interesting yeah
certain affinity was basically a support
studio all these years and now they're
getting that the chance to make their
own ip there that's a big budget game um
monster hunter style
game could be awesome um
is it i mean xbox has been trying to
diversify their portfolio in game pass
and
monster hunter type of game fits
basically many needs yeah it's it's
it's a genre that they don't have right
now it's an ongoing game it's a game as
a service kind of game um
definitely sounds interesting um
and that multiplayer mode yeah yeah i've
read a lot of things about that a lot of
speculations out there but since they
said it's going to be in probably an
approachable
new game mode i i immediately thought
that is probably something pve related
right right where the the the casual
gamers don't
go into the pvp aspect um that much
especially when a game is out already
for a while yeah then to enter the pvp
um multiplayer modes is can be kind of
frustrating so having that pve kind of
mode would definitely make sense they
had something that like that in halo 5
with with that uh what's it called uh
warsaw
yeah warzone mode something like that
yeah um
yeah no fair enough fair enough i mean
i was gonna say not to mention like when
it comes to
just this particular thing with monster
hunter like
mozzarella is such a big franchise it's
a huge franchise and and there's people
that try to do stuff similar but no it's
really it facts so it's kind of like to
say the pokemon thing like pokemon is
such a unique formula that you eat that
that kind of would seem it would be easy
to replicate you know what i'm saying
but no one's been able to successfully
do it no that's a good point
solve the three rumors gears collection
certain affinity monster hunter co-op
game and halo infinite casual mode where
we at
all right so the three gears games um i
agree with boxing burger 100 and and
addict i mean i don't think because of
the way these games run in in back
compat mode and fps boost and all that
stuff don't really need it right now but
they are in terms of the amount of games
that they that they have it they they do
fit in that sort of master chief
collection sort of bundle type of thing
um and again making them prettier
is never a bad thing i just think
because of how those games run and why
it's not necessary right now i kind of
agree with attic you know get the
redheaded stepchild his love yeah you
know
fables coming down the pipeline in in a
year or two
get the hype train going exactly uh i
would definitely like to see that that
would be nice um and do you remember
there was this weird tweet that weird
tweet if they slipped up
yeah yeah i forgot about it
yeah it's nothing there's nothing
nothing's happening it turns out to be
nothing and it turned out to be
mm-hmm
so i think that was mainly because at
the time
the game wasn't 60 frames and that big
update
it was it turned to 60 frames so i think
i remember that was about because like a
week later they did that update on fable
with the other game so i think they just
jumped the gun on that particular part
now the multiplayer mode that is for
halo that is kind of more in line
with like casual gamers
i think it's interesting because when
you look at like you look at the success
of a fortnight away and that's what i'm
looking at because in terms of casual
nothing else really appeals like if you
think of apex it's not really for
casuals a lot of people play it but it's
not really a casual game obviously pubg
not a cabbage game those type of games
so it's interesting to me that that they
specified casual because fortnite
that would
which is which was super interesting
because the thing is if you look at halo
in terms of the skill it takes to play
halo well yeah it's a different type of
skill and i would argue maybe a little
kind of heavier skill base than maybe
even call of duty right call of duty
there's certain things there's a cadence
to the game playing call of duty that
isn't what halo is halo is a lot more
tactical um
and for me to change that into something
that is kind of digestible for a more
casual audience
may blow up in their face but again
the potential for a free-to-play halo
having
an aspect of it that kind of opens it up
to even more people yeah is super
interesting i don't know if it's battle
royale because about battle royal at its
core i would think the gameplay is still
core gameplay halo right gameplay so i i
don't know what that means but it's very
interesting because that could mean like
a like a shift in what people expect
from halo especially
if this is its own thing right so that
is that's cool i i would definitely be
interested to see what what that is but
that's
i don't know what those two two things
don't necessarily coincide in my
thinking so
did you comment on the monster hunter
thing so certain affinity right uh like
boxing burger said this is this is uh
this is a studio that's always been in
support they help make uh they help make
master chief collection they help make a
halo anniversary edition
they've helped do a lot of multiplayer
maps for anna that halo 2 anniversary
and and and for infinite you know and
then past halo games as well
um they're only two
they're only two uh games of note that
they've made themselves the only two
ones they made themselves are a game
called age of booty that came out on
xbox 360.
and then there's another one called
crimson alliance just like uh like uh
what you'll call like a multi-player
yeah so that that is them beyond that
they haven't done anything but support
so to for them to get the chance to do
this they've always done quality work as
well so
it's cool they finally get the chance to
shine on their own now when it comes to
monster hunter that's interesting as
well because
monster hunter at least at least with
world
is now going to every platform right
with monsanto rise hasn't come to
xbox yet um it's only on pc and switch
still right now it's not on playstation
either right
so
we're getting monster hunter on multiple
platforms right but the thing about it
is it may be way too expensive to pay
for monster hunter on game pads
like it just it just may be way too
expensive for them to even think about
doing that so
when you think about creating something
that lives on that platform constantly
and it's something up to the quality of
monster hunter and i agree with attic it
can't be see if you make something
that's a reasonable facsimile of
something
and it falls short in anything
you were just going to gravitate to the
original thing right like and so you
have to be very careful when you sort of
mimic something um
i i would definitely be interested in
something of that ilk where you're
hunting whatever because king and i have
tried multiple times to play monster
hunter hey
speaking of the co-op
another platform and online
infrastructure
i actually really like the monster
hunter world
i have like three days in that game oh
crash but even then even then is there
something about that combat i'm not a
fan of it just feels i just i'm not a
fan so seriously
you know it is so if you if microsoft
can do something in that realm that is
different and still has you know
obviously it's going to be a service
based game it's going to be some but if
they can take that idea and expand upon
it in really interesting ways and have
it live in game pass that's going to be
huge for them so i don't begrudge them
going they're taking that shot
if they're doing that um and then that
was that it yeah yeah that was it
king where we at collection first you
want the gears you want the fable and
then about this monster honey game and a
halo infinite casual mode
this is this is beautiful
conversation surrounded by all these
rumors yes
well first when it comes to gears you
can never have too much
never have too much
all right so so put that's like ketchup
put a little bit more ketchup please
i like it on my french fries you know
you ever get a ketchup pack and you have
your french fries
you always need one more pack right put
a little bit more drizzle on that
oh you know um yeah
you know when they said that i was like
yeah they did just have a release on
something i could take that
like do you want to play gears like that
oh here we go here we go
the game play hour shavings
here we go what i would suggest you do
is take yourself and throw yourself in
the bushes with your plates first right
legs first
i need to check your xbox live i don't
want you to do dan why don't you go
check out mel and buster one while
you're doing that oh mail and bust for
once
you're giving me someone else's game or
time no that would say that that would
be giving you mine
oh
hey look halo trailer is out just say i
know oh hello is out
yeah before you toss yourself out the
window i want you to take your legs and
throw yourself kindly and gently into
the brooklyn
gently why why are you doing that you
know checking on my resume why don't you
look at my neogeo stuff too while you're
at it oh they don't exist
when you was born i still got more
gaming years for you now oh stop it here
we go okay
now thank you yes
i don't know why he does that don't come
for me unless i send him ball for y'all
or messi
so
back to what i was saying uh
good cap messi
[Laughter]
anyway so yeah more gears more gears
more gears and more gears on top of more
gears uh you know you got to go with the
successful hand i mean it's a royal
flush every time you put it out it sells
well and it caters to a certain crowd
that actually love it now um
as the multiplayer goes the only thing i
was really enthusiastic with gears was
like hard mode and i don't really care
too much about their multiplayer to be
honest with you that cover-based stuff
i'm
i just never was really too good at it
so i just like you know threw it away
because the learning curve on that is
insane yeah um and and people that
actually have a down pack actually have
a supreme advantage over you you know
for noobs
um
but yeah i would love to see i would
love to see an actual remake in a horror
vein
of gears one oh let's go and how they
wanted to make the krill in the dark
gary and then
because i think those earlier games were
really dark pretty much in their
projection of what they wanted gears to
do you saw the berserker for the first
time and the thing yeah absolutely scary
stuff um
the monster hunter stuff oh the fable
stuff yeah i think they will i think
right before fable is uh probably six
months to uh eight months out
they're going to give you something to
what's your palate to get you
reintroduced to the world to to bring
you up to speed so i don't think you get
both you didn't get both yeah i believe
so i believe it's necessary and they can
do so
in in the game pass structure where they
can keep keep people abreast of what's
coming forward they they do that a lot
okay um so i i don't ever think you know
just because one is being made that
doesn't mean the other one is not being
yeah right you know the studios are vast
and they do have a lot of support
studios or whatever that stuff can get
done and get done at a high quality yeah
um
and they showed that they've actually
shown that they're willing to do so and
i would like a master chief type of
gears uh all in house type of things
that you can go to
not how you know halo
anniversary i don't know
like a second triad something good
please
um
the last game
i've told you dudes long time ago that
they were going to make uh uh
a pub g type halo
thing and i think the activision
uh thought really
accelerated that right because if you
have
probably
some of the best stuff there with uh war
zone and overwatch you pretty much can
go in there and pick their brains into
uh putting your
uh game into that a whole uh space
now i think looking at fortnite and i
might be a little bit biased right now
because that thing is consuming my time
right now but if you can
do casualize halo to a point
that it can fit into because warzone is
hard car core like when you look at it
as far as the visual goes right um
the most appealing aspect of fortnite is
it's so unassuming
in the thought that it looks kitty it
looks like anybody can join in and that
was a barrier for me at first until you
actually got into it and realized that
there was skill involved
if they can get and and don't do
the same thing that they're doing with
their multiplayer with the halo
and do something that can uh
their fiance
hard with that work
halo in such a such a sense that it can
stand out i think they can actually
achieve this i really think
it's something that they can do
in that sense of having
a team base you can do uh solos you can
do duos you can do uh squads
uh
this thing can happen but they have to
nail it right and i hope it is and and
the fact that it's casual base that
means that uh probably the respawn time
back into the world is very quickly you
know it's not something that uh that has
a sharp edge to it in learning curve
because halo multiplayer has a sharp
edge to it if you're playing against
seasoned dudes they get that grappling
hook shotgun
so
maybe this changes that whole narrative
i do want it in the vein of
dancing uh the emotes mean a lot
you want that
yeah i do
against people in fortnight and this
dude had cradles the other day mm-hmm
doing the rolly-rolly watch me there
that thing
i'm not gonna lie
i don't even get upset when i lose
because sometimes they dab on you after
they kill you like yeah so it's certain
things and and
i'm telling you
anytime you can get me to spend money in
a game that's free
you got me hooked i went and bought the
boba fett whole thing right and they had
it and i was like and the music
yo this if they can do it if they can
nail it
that's the only thing that they have to
they gotta have dancing
because i love the dancing that's in
destiny i love that stuff
because don't lie
don't lie when you when you have a good
gear good clothes
a good emote that thing actually works
no i get it i get it i just don't think
that community what's that but i don't
care about that community i don't know
listen you know why i don't care about
that y'all already got exactly what
y'all wanted i got the single player
joint you got the co-op coming you got
the forge and you got the multi-player
what about long side thing go ahead go
ahead
look real quick y'all i don't know if
y'all saw it the halo trailer just
dropped
good
lord
i don't know if you guys saw it i put it
i put it in our personal chat and i put
it in on
youtube just now not for y'all to leave
but it's that crazy so all your spare
time it is absolutely nuts um
and i'm feeling i'm feeling the chief
yeah yes yes yes you're about to say
something when you're talking to a king
you're about to say something yeah i i
agree with king when it comes to the
emotes and stuff really
at the end of the day
just because those emotes and the master
chief going to the the cha-cha slide
it doesn't mean you have to do it like
it's just like one of those things where
people want to do it they can do it sure
that takes away from like the realism a
little bit like you know the serious
tone but master chief's like eight foot
tall anyway so like
like
the trailer just down for the paramount
no i was going to look at it after the
party oh you need to see that you don't
need to see that boxing you saw it
no i'm going to watch it oh we're
watching yourself
all right i gotta figure out how to
watch the actual series people people
are like live reactions yeah they want
the live reaction it's crazy it's crap
wow wow i didn't think the boat was
gonna be that yeah um so yeah i'll jump
in um
i'm with king mostly because
with the um
look
fable deserves it yes
i understand favorite desserts they
deserve it they deserve a collection i
get it you know what i'm saying but it's
just like to me selfish cog
you know i was upset when what was it
when we um when it was give gears one
ultimate edition
and then it's like we're not gonna do
the treatment rest of that just go to
the rest of it which is weird yeah just
just go to back and fast and that's nice
but it's like i just played at this high
level with this fidelity and the 64. now
you're telling me to go play the old one
that just faster and i'm like nah give
me the whole thing and
i'm gonna be real like i want the full
treatment with that joint you don't say
so for me i think you know gears 1-3
judgment i think was unique because they
had the random like enemy spawn points
it was based on how you played and stuff
like that you know i would love the full
graphical treatment the fidelity
influence infused life into the
multiplayer i think we're forgetting
the pc community did not get a chance to
get those gears games a lot of them
right so you're this is a whole back end
catalog for those guys at microsoft
let's be honest that's that's money
right there especially with this
ecosystem that you're trying to do so
you do that you know um
i am curious if gears 4 will be included
in that um because it's kind of recent
yeah i don't know if y'all think it
would be or not but yeah i think so it's
already in game pass so it doesn't make
any sense i mean in terms of read i mean
yeah i mean the four and five it just
don't need anything i i doubt it's it's
two three in judgement i think yeah so
it'd be interesting they play four but
no i i think it i think it's good
apparently it was rumored that even if
this is being made
it's not going to be by the core studios
like the coalition's not making this
playground right making it what makes it
yeah yeah and part of me
if it's not going to be closely looked
at which that doesn't mean it's not
going to be closely looked at but we we
saw what happened with with the halo one
where it's just like oh something i
don't want no one touching these games
but the but but the people making these
games because i feel like
like sometimes stuff gets thrown out
there that's not done and it's just like
if if it works the way it's supposed to
at launch sure but if you're gonna give
me uh something even it don't even have
to be similar to halo if you're gonna
give me anything on the same levels of
what master chief came out with just
just cancel it now like i mean look they
one would hope that they've learned from
those mistakes and at the end of the day
you know coalition's big you would think
they're gonna lean in to whoever the
support studios lean into exactly what
the vision is and it's not really like
you have to do there's existing assets
it's not you know for for the most part
and then they can work around it but i
am happy i'm with king i'm not in the
multiplayer but i'm happy for the horde
modes coming back and then there's a
community like i said on pc and cross
play and all the stuff they're trying to
do they'll get to the play now as far as
the monster hunter thing i am not a
monster hunter guy but i understand how
important that thing is people love it i
mean i i don't like i mean i tried it i
get why people like it anything about
that monster crap yeah
monster hunter and if they make the game
please make it better than that
just let you join with your friend easy
you know what i said because that
clearly was an issue with nintendo and
um look right graphical fidelity please
make it look nice
that may be upset halo
worlds uh
the uh
monster awards look good no no dad i'm
talking about like i know that look good
i'm not saying monster hunter don't look
i meant to say whatever this
monster hunter like game that they're
trying to do make it look good like i
want to see
graphics pushed i want to see me yeah
part of me feels like it
i mean unless microsoft's really going
to back the truck up for the funding of
this game pardon me feels like it's
going to be cartoony
whatever we got to see i want to look
good
whatever dude look good play good have a
good co-op satiate that's got a
yeah we're gonna get it um yeah so look
uh certainly with the co-publishing i
like that they what i like about it is
that they're shooting this shot in the
genre that they know they have i think
it's funny song that they realize
catcalling a little too expensive and
they're probably never going to be able
to get that so yo make our own
like i like it but that's the
the expense they know it's expensive the
game's gonna be expensive especially
they could have done it a couple years
ago before monsanto world blew up right
on this side of the world because before
it was
that they do it after the game blew up
because now more people are familiar
with that type of game yeah the genre
yeah yeah so i mean do do your thing do
your thing yeah yeah and like i said
co-op monster under good graph is good i
mean i play game pass ain't no reason
for me not to play it right then that's
right so i'm in you know yeah all
blessed god say less you know what
i didn't get to say anything about the
uh the halo yes yes please go um
i think it is a battle royale because
like to me
this company's helped them in the past
before
you know
help microsoft with halo but it was
always like 343 was working on the next
halo game or 343 was working on this or
three like that 343 wasn't working on
the game really that much anymore it was
always on to the next project and they
they would help do something with the
game while they were waiting for that
but yeah what's different about this is
like the whole company 343 is focused on
halo right so it's on the game that
they're making it for so to me it's like
unless it's something massive yeah why
would they need their help making a game
mode yeah it is interesting to see that
they're being brought in you're so
you're making fantastic points i think
um shout out to jazz in um his article
he said the the mode will look to hook
into halo infinite's upcoming forge mode
according to his information a feature
player created feature player created
content is a core part of the experience
would also leverage existing cosmetics
from halo infinite existing multiplayer
progression and potentially have a new
progression system of its own on top you
know me personally i'm with king i'm not
even a battle royal glute like that but
i do i would like to see it knowing my
luck
it's gonna be boyzo
and i got that against one so i had to
get
but i do feel i'm with king like you got
to get that player that's not going to
play that type of halo you got to get a
different player that'll say okay you
know what i don't really rock with that
tactical and all that hardcore arena
stuff but hey you give me an emo you
give me throw me on an island the zeto
you know a mini version of zeta halo and
you go you know who run into a building
and get some equipment and then you get
people will get it there's a casual base
that will get into that and i hope they
take a little bit of the war zone flavor
you know mix with a little fortnight and
hey i mean i don't i don't approve of
the dances but i understand
it's a different market yeah
here's the biggest question if they do
do this
is this going to be something
that is its own unique client within a
different jump uh that's a good question
or is it going to be something
integrated into the halo infinite that's
a good question that's going to be the
key is it just gonna be as simple as
like when you played warzone on halo 5
and click it it's just a separate
category i honestly believe once they
figure
what the game is going to look and feel
like
that's going to dictate
if it's in that client like because if
it if it's so
visually different
from halo
it might be its separate own package
right but if if if it does use assets of
the halo universe um
then of course it would be you know
in the same browser no doubt and final
thing real quick live reactions for
dozer's head i don't know if boxer
burger got a chance to sneak something
into that trailer while you talk boxer
burger really quick what did you think
about that halo infinite paramount movie
trailer what's up
it looks crazy that looks really really
crazy the production quality is through
the roof
um all these people looking at this
podcast when they're supposed to be in
the park listen listen that was breaking
news
yeah exactly we we're the first to get
it
[Laughter]
i know it looks absolutely awesome now
we gotta figure out how to watch it
we don't have paramount blasts here oh
we're gonna have to get some burner
accounts we're gonna have to get him
cracking oh
we gotta i gotta figure that out but uh
yeah it looks awesome um
we look crazy no doubt no doubt who else
get a chance to stick song
did you get a chance to sneak it
no i'm going to watch it after the paw
patrol okay good solve what you're
taking
yeah man everything like the production
value it feels like this was made by
people who know understand and care
about halo yes um
um we're not getting steve downs as the
voice of master chief and that's fine
pablo schreiber's voice so far sounds
cool
um there might be i i have a feeling
some people might have some some some
thoughts on cortana
but it but it is the cortana actress so
um
just because people like
she doesn't quite look exactly like she
looks like a human like a human little
projection yeah
but i like the way she looks um but
everything that i saw in that trailer
wow wow
wow
wow and this is why this is why thank
goodness
yeah bikini
baby got a job for strapping yeah
[Music]
the lady that um
did john i mean the one that um
what's the hell doctor
yeah
yeah she's there she's not she's not as
old as she as in
i see what you're saying with the
cortana human thing but i don't mind i
don't mind no i i like this looks great
yeah she's a halo though i mean she's um
a holographic illusion uh yeah they got
the universe down bro down that's what
it feels like from from the trailers
let's try the trash yeah from the
trailer for the trunks
these whoever but the spartans look good
that's my main thing like usually you
know a man in the suit you want you
gonna feel like you might look cheesy
look at the br these look crazy
you see how big the leafs is over yeah
yeah
you got to watch it and i'm like i'm
like i'm like how they they they're
addressing the whole thing that the
spartans were made to to shut down
insurrections and now
the tables turn then you they have to
become heroes for humanity yeah um i
love that i love that
yeah because they weren't necessarily a
lot of they were built to murder human
beings
they were they were
a strong arm type of thing exactly you
know and they needed to turn around to
save humanity
and um
this story would be great but again uh
service announcement to anyone who's
willing to share this
yeah i gotta get down i even realized
that hit me up because uh you know this
is what it is i gotta talk to kaga about
some stars okay
[Laughter]
remember they were doing the halo
universe a minute ago yeah and um who
was who was tasked with doing that
wasn't that um
a very big name uh james cameron oh no
you talked about the dude i know you
talking about the dude
well spielberg was the one they were
talking about it wasn't a movie though
it was supposed to be the series
correct
but when they were talking about doing a
movie of it they were trying to get neil
blom camp to do it okay so but okay so
i'm just gonna go off the steven
spielberg stuff
maybe this is the same script
you know maybe this is the same script
that they was trying to get out and then
when they uh got rid of the the um the
movie studios uh they farmed it out and
got paramount to uh you know uh do the
script
this stuff looks like it looks
phenomenal it really does and the thing
about it i i just wanted to add is that
i kind of like that it ended up
happening this way because sometimes
let's be honest sometimes you can't get
everything
in a movie within time constraints so
there's always gonna be cuts but with a
series at least you can stretch this out
and we're seeing video games now really
taking shine with like witcher and stuff
like that but this is a lot of care fan
service graphic fidelity production they
look like it went i did not to be honest
did not expect to look this good yeah
well i do ever since uh disney plus
and you get a chance to see how they
handle their streaming uh
movies and shows
um
like one division
uh captain america and winter soldier
yeah all the way to boba fett uh the
book of boba fett right now and the
mandalorian
they are they were able to craft worlds
in such a manner and i think that is uh
triculate to what's going on at
paramount right now because yeah these
stories that they're being told
on these different uh streaming shows
they need these content and they
understand to keep people engaged yeah
quality has to be high billboards and
what i've noticed with me the chat is
saying stillberg spielberg is a producer
on the show at this point you guys might
as well just put the damn trailer on the
screen and play it
though people do people do reactions all
the time
without the sound they hit us hard
though but um
i say this i mean the worst they could
do is take the hat revenues
everybody's watched it already and
everybody's got to see me
but if
disney has done with the unreal engine
because unreal engine actually they do
everything in that studio an unreal
action unreal engine facilitates the
world
a lot of studios is taking this aspect
of it and using high quality assets
without putting out high production as
far as value goes with the what um
the the money goes so
production cost is lower
quality is up and i think they've
reached a happy medium that we will see
a lot of the stuff that we like on these
screens because that halo
ridiculous yeah take take notice take
note of this naughty dog and uncharted
please oh yeah
until dawn was was that was a good uh
movie i really like that i got to check
that out yeah no at the end of the day
like until dawn
it's like until dawn it's like forward
onto dawn i think that's what it was
called go forward until you mean that oh
yeah
no no that was nice i like that yeah no
doubt yeah
it's just like look at the other day the
reason that we're starting to see
better
takes on certain things is gamers are
growing up to actually do these films
now so
you know back in the day when people try
to do it it wasn't gamers i mean i can't
say it wasn't 100 gamers but a lot of
people felt like all the gaming
industry's grown let's just throw
anything out there we can make money off
of it yeah it's not like that anymore
and i think because the the ones that
have failed
they know that it's like look like these
gamers they savages like if we don't do
exactly what they want like
they won't watch our stuff like do we
boycott our own industry at least seven
eight times a year what makes you think
we want more guys you're right about
that you're right about that and it's
just like if you look at it from the
standpoint on like you know what's uh
you know what's a movie that i'll always
watch no matter what
sonic
because when that sonic thing looked
horrible oh yeah they pushed that back
and cost them millions yeah but they did
that for us and that's why i will always
support that oh yeah for sure yeah they
most would not have done and went back
most of them are like you get what you
get what you get yeah no doubt no doubt
somebody's saying that there's a penis
and butt head there's another one
it's beavis and butthead and like
cartman they all sing in the halo theme
there's a cover of the halo theme oh
this is crazy yeah we're going to have
to get it oh it's all in the family now
you know how i go
let's get out of here we will uh that
was our little semi-live reaction while
it went live on ilp
um actually you want me to while you
keep this super chats you want me to get
the uh poll yep okay and then we'll get
boxy burger guy who's been very patient
and cool you guys throw the chat uh the
the uh trailer in the chat a couple
times people was asking yeah i thought
in there right now
bam
so we got that you're in there um all
right so new ip poll out of all the
recently rumored xbox game pass studio
or actually xbox game studios leagues
which one of these would you prefer to
happen
first the choices are a halo infinite
battle royale or halo 5 war zone spin
off
b
xbox exclusive co-op take or monster
hunter c gears of war or fable
collection or d i don't care i'm still
talking about this call of duty
exclusivity though
all the people it's gonna be the i don't
care for every question for like teen
moms baby
speculation will continue we already
know and again shout out to the
legendary
boxing burger rock out with us i can say
one thing yes i had this individual on
addict show before he came out
for once ever
salute man definitely man it's germany's
finest salute to you brother finally got
it done rocked with us the whole way
where can i find people find you what
you got going on sir
yeah thanks so much for the invite it's
been awesome hanging with you guys um so
much left or so much fun here um
thank you so much it was awesome
yeah people can find me basically
everywhere on the boxenberger yeah here
on youtube twitter xbox on playstation
network everywhere
under boxenburger
yeah i get the world of gaming coming up
of course next week um i already have
the next video uploaded for channel
members it's going live to the public
tomorrow um
and i have a couple of things planned
for
hopefully february but it's probably
going to be march
no um
some cool cool stuff coming on the
channel um the podcast is going very
well the feedback has been awesome nice
um i've got a couple of cool cats
scheduled already um it's going to be
fun all right all right let's get this
channel in there
right quick let me take care box burger
right quick so people know they could
find where to find them i'm gonna put
his link in the description right now
they said channel please late play all
right i got you i got you hustle's not
in there usually hustle be in there take
care of that for me so i gotta do the
manual work today so there you go make
sure you subscribe germany's finest
right there he'll pronounce
wolfenstein and horizon
okay
what does it mean what does it mean
the hedgehog is duke and zwei is to duke
number two yeah
i didn't know that okay
yeah check that out man you already know
also let's give um alex give uh boxing
burger his roses on the way out
i appreciate you coming on uh it's
always it's always nice to see people's
perspective that's not in america yes
because uh i do feel like us as
americans sometimes we we like to put
ourselves in a big iron box that only
feel like rp's better better just our
opinions so it's nice to get other
people's opinions on them no doubt no
thank you thank you you know it's been
awesome so ava can you want to give a
box of burger his flowers before he
leaves yes sir big shout out to you sir
i i just love the fact that you know
this community is just we all
we're here to build each other up yes
and every single week we see more and
more examples of that
people that have been in the space
a shorter time than we have longer time
than we have and you know rising tide
sort of lifts all boats and the fact
that that you're getting more notoriety
now for being on these different shows
and we've grown and it's it's just an
amazing thing to see so keep doing what
you're doing brother uh absolutely
amazing work
um and you know where you can find me i
have to go shave and actually no i have
to
shout out to april i this is going to be
my first lord's minute of the month
that's how crazy the month's been wow so
i'll be i'll be recording with lady
april in about an hour and a half so
shout out to that absolute salute you
already know can you want to get vacant
burgers flowers on the way out
well germany stand up
he's upside down in the multiverse gotta
go cause you know he boy but he you know
control himself germany stand up yes let
me let me tell you something um
listening to your history this is this
is the real reason why i like people on
right um to gain uh
an insight on
your whole gaming history on on you as a
person you know a lot of people won't
get that from your channel going to your
channel because you're you're usually
reporting on what's going on and current
trends and stuff like that and
this is like a diverge from that to get
to know who you are this is like uh like
a little notation on boxing burger was
here today and
i i found out that his first console
that he purchased with his money
was uh nintendo 64. i found out that he
built his own pc without any guidelines
and and really his ingenuity i found out
that he decided that
they weren't doing localization
he was going to do his own localization
you know and you know we will always
talk on every other show that we're on
mid-week mix up or whatever
you know i would get a chance to see you
but i'm like man come on man get on get
on camera yeah and then you know you
would hit me with you with your channel
in the background and then i will
automatically support get that out there
watch get those views up and i will
watch the whole video it's a whole
entirety i believe that means a lot to
people you know just don't go in and hit
a like and walk out the door the
algorithm sees that sit there and watch
the video um leave a comment if you can
under um under the person's video show
some type of engagement some type of
encouragement and it's great to see that
right now brother to be honest with you
you know to see you from space a to
space b and you're just gonna go keep
going up straight up um and i'm glad
that you got a chance to find out how
great this community is
you know um thank you everybody will
look out for each other and that's how
it's supposed to be facts you know and
and i see that across the board so thank
you for showing up sharing a part of
yourself with us thank you so much
you know we here brother thank you so
much
hello oh and y'all guys can catch me on
twitter being as messy as i'm gonna be i
was a little bit tame today uh because
uh numbers speak for themselves and um
yeah y'all could want y'all could hope
y'all could pray
that sony will oh no
news tomorrow
[Laughter]
i don't know if he's still rocking i
know he's at his four-hour limit and
we've got super chats to read so if
we're rocking fine but we gotta
i'll i'll have a couple of more minutes
okay google just wanna make sure all
right so i'll solve your queued up
yeah i'm ready to go all right let's do
it we have mr irishman five pound super
chat get the coalition on the 13 13 game
featuring mando instead of boba yeah
let's do that like that okay no
and we have donald t nope
five dollars
nah bruh the fps boosters fable was not
what that tweet was about damn taco just
dropping like yeah yeah yeah
spicy with both of you
i hope
i hope that i hope it wasn't about that
but i'm just telling you it was awful
coincidence that that tweet is put out
and erased and then a week later fable
gets a 60 frames patch that's all i'm
saying well if nothing if nothing fable
related comes out until fable
4 or whatever
then we know that that's what it was
because what else could it have been you
just could come out and say something
for no reason
remember that the tweet came from xbox
publishing account not the main xbox i
don't know that nice boost nice booth
if they can make a monster hunter clone
that actually appeals to what people
love about the original that could be
big for their place in japan as it's one
of the biggest franchises there that's
one thing we didn't touch on the fact
that they make something very
japanese-centric because again i think a
lot of
monster hunters bigger now in the west
because of
changes that they made to the core sort
of
yeah
so maybe we'll see yeah
we had
do you think microsoft are making their
own monster hunter game because they are
worried about sony buying capcom and
locking away the ip
you never know sometimes you got to make
a defensive move
but but let's be honest like these
a lot of these insider like some people
have an idea of what someone else is
going to do that's right you know what i
mean
and we can't we exactly we can't act
like last generation you know way the
way capcom was moving with them with
street fighter making that exclusive and
that relationship's there so who knows
that street fighter 5 was so surprising
to me yes
very surprised i was like that's a great
multi-player
let a cop come yeah and i do want to
point out that like i don't think that's
the core reason right but that might be
one of those things where it's like
because let's be right here
microsoft knew when they bought the
activision that there might be some
consequences for that
so they're like look if they buy
capcom
hopefully we'll have something to
replace them look if they already
do they're doing what tony should have
done
like if they already according to grub
worrying about the the cost just to put
it in game pass you know is too much not
worth it dead is like metrics yeah the
other monster hunter that it ain't worth
it make our own because we don't need to
give you a bag for something that we
don't own for something that's not gonna
stick around and didn't do as much as
they thought they did and what i like
i'll be honest is the first
making your own i kind of like that i
like that like yo let's try let's give
her you know say i like that they'll get
the [ __ ] out of here
you know what i really you know what i
really like the fact that a studio
that's always been a support studio is
getting the opportunity yeah absolutely
unlike ben you know ben got a shot you
know did it work out no uh yeah whatever
they say whatever but you know that's
about studio now they don't [ __ ] ask
you got any more avrex jackets man he
loving your favorite levels from back he
loving that man well i don't have any
averages but what you will see is the
peles you know all the averages this is
what i do
you know um i had a ton of average
jackets and what i would do is go out
and give them to homeless people yeah i
remember that i do yeah when i went when
i made my switch like i switched all my
peles over um from averages
and you know i just went out i went my
girl thought i was bugging one day i
just drove up to this dude that i see in
the supermarket that was packing bags
all the time and i just gave him a rex
jacket that's what's up sauce
chats finished yeah we got a few more we
have uh brett bring them two dollar
super chat that halo series on paramount
plus trailer
i don't know what to do
it's going down what's a halo i never
heard of that
we have voidlock spartan two dollars
with chat have you seen the witch queen
exotic preview
oh i haven't seen what this is about i
gotta go watch that this week i'm buying
my uh witch queen stuff um wait i
thought she was gonna hold out to the
very last video
they not going in game pass nope nope
nope that deal is done it's set and halo
has taken over
okay fair enough then we have eg kenta
five dollars talking about mario kart a
few years ago i bought a used black wii
u from a pawn shop and got the game for
free digital see padding the numbers
why are you gonna stay black though yeah
the way you said it
[Laughter]
moving on
there we got wandering dutch five
thousand
you all see the halo tv series trailer
which dropped just now iop who did that
for you
bro that was fire okay
yeah i can't wait to watch it in 4k i'm
about to go we might have to drop some
uh patreon and members exclusive stuff
talking about our opinions on
the show when it comes to yeah yeah
we might have to do show we show you
usually yeah weekly yeah why not yeah
yeah i like that i like that i'm back
for that that we fire
donald taco 5
certain affinity mostly works on
realistic triple a games and there's
already a cartoony monster hunter like
pointless who said i expected
i expect realistic graphics for their
game yeah okay all right that'll be sick
i like that give me confidence and we
have done otaku again steven spielberg
is still attached to the show so he's
still attached to the show i think that
leads well into something mm-hmm
and then the chat also told us that yeah
it was it was um peter jackson and then
neil blunt
but i said yeah initially they were
talking about all the weather and what
they were going to do with the special
effects and all that stuff yeah
and we have brett bingham again five
dollars a chat oh my god there is a new
paramount commercial with beavis and
butthead singing the halo theme a
mountain of entertainment i got to see
that as well
um let me see if anything else popped in
something
yeah voidlock spartan 2 super chat they
should buy the creator of dauntless to
make it hmm okay now i'm cool with them
giving this to these people
let them try
these guys are pros they've been working
on they've been trusted they deserved it
and they deserve that
yeah
if they hit it out of the park they
deserve that microsoft money to buy oh
this is what i'm saying like if they hit
it out the park then they deserve to do
whatever they they have on there and i
think microsoft is in a position where
they can give a lot of these support
studios a chance to do something and to
see you know test your might see yeah
testile might i like that okay i think
that's gonna be the new wave and we know
we always get into the whole nurturing
thing but i think a lot of thing now is
like all right we're gonna do this
co-publishing deal we'll see how you do
with this we'll see how red four go and
we'll see how perfect
earn your strike let's see there yo if a
relationship is good then we continue
and i like that approach
do you see
when you have the ability to have your
stuff already stocking up and
it's called time they didn't have time
when they got in because it was up
against the clock but right now you able
to do some nurturing stuff that
everybody claims that sony was doing
and can i say something real quick
before we go off like i'm tired of this
nurturing thing look i'm not saying sony
doesn't do a decent job at nurturing
they do yeah but you know
shout out to k mega because he said
something that didn't really click until
he said it let's go nurturing something
is like buying a studio like compulsion
undead labs something that's growing
them not a lot and growing them to the
point where you feel like you've
actually contributed to them i will i'm
i'm i'm 100 on this standstill buying a
company like insomniac games you just
funneled money into it for 10 15 years
in my opinion now is not nurturing right
if you would have bought them 10 15
years ago it nurtured because all you
really did is fund the money and they
nurtured the damn self yeah so and you
know what's what's funny too is people
are acting like microsoft and sony has
been nurturing these publishers for
decades yeah with the bethesda they
literally helped them breed oblivion on
the platform yeah yep todd went to um
them when they had the fallout 76 issues
morrowind from the og
morrowind from the og xbox yeah like
which got boxing virgo into x-files
right we talked about like this is how
we're coming full circle but look
nurturing or not i don't care i don't
care if it's an indie studio
they knew each other i mean dudes who's
in the cut they knew each other since
high school if the game is whack it
don't matter so i don't care how you got
the studio make the game fire that's all
i care um i want to get one it's a super
chat because i got to get a merch if the
super chat nah we're good okay cool and
shout out to eberrato he got the polo he
gonna make king man he got the 10k pull
over hoodie and white before he went no
you ain't making me mad this is i'm just
telling you guys listen if y'all are
part of something special yeah and when
we pull it out pause
um that's it
you know so the next shirt will probably
be 20k
um or
whatever but
do you know how hard it is to get 10k
people yeah like i mean that was an
absolute struggle so we decided to sit
back in the background to to do
something to commemorate that
for for everybody that was there like if
you was there before we even got 100
people nobody was rocking please you
know and
just go get it because
i love that shirt i really love it i
love the design i i wish i knew what it
looked like mine got stolen we're going
to reply
yes
i love a job
you know and listen anybody that needs
artwork and stuff like that please go to
dinero on twitter dinero panel go to him
uh give him
he does phenomenal work please just
reach out to him give him that bread
because i'm gonna tell you he's very
professional very quick and very clean
and he communicates very well no yeah
he's awesome to work with he also did
the channel intro from for my channel oh
yeah
yeah and i think he did booms one of the
booms too he's been on fire man shout
out to daenerys you know what i'm saying
yeah
and dinero when you hit this up man uh
uh
hit me up
yeah and uh somebody want the link for
the merch merch link is at the top pi5
is at the top it's pinned at the top of
the chat right now you can go for the
live stream
we're going to close that probably in
the next hour so you guys better buy
that
next hour i'm not going to close it in
the next hour i'm going to leave it up
to eight o'clock tonight after the
football games yeah and then i'm gonna
dead it yeah yeah hit p up you already
know
yeah i put the the link in for
founders show jump over to the show he's
talking to dealer right now
what's this what's up that's what's up
you already know anybody got anything
else when we get out of here we good yo
what's up
i was gonna say uh tomorrow at 5 00 p.m
because i'm starting to feel a little
bit better i've been sick for like two
weeks
um and then i went straight from the
holidays to being sick
and now i'm starting to feel a little
bit better so yeah
hello
go from that
and um tomorrow at 5 p.m i will be
streaming battle toads i want to get
that out of there
[Applause]
i will stream it for two hours
i i apologize in advance yes
he gonna throw that all the way in the
bushes i can't wait i want to see the
attic pissed off part that's what i
wanted yeah it's gonna be called
millennium plays battletoads i love it
because the thing is the other games you
played are are good games battletoad
isn't really a good
god at all
they want to see that they want to see
you earn difficult gay cover for all
those frauds that was sitting there
going against the new battle toads
talking about oh no oh what the og shut
up you don't know nothing
anyway anybody got anything else
we are good
and and i will be great next week okay
i'm going back to the 80s yes please we
like your colors we like you look
everybody enjoy your sunday again boxer
burger salute for rocking with us we
will be back more fun more good topics
more good guests and uh appreciate your
support y'all peace
[Music]
hmm
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you